you know the world may be ending peter
thiel's trying to build some like new
zealand bunker or whatever resorts a
bunch of global elites have been
preparing for something and maybe it's
just because
they can they have money what else you
gonna buy so build yourself a missile
silo bunker i guess or maybe maybe the
world is ending well we will talk about
that but i kind of felt like it'd be
more fun to to tackle some cultural
issues because we have the story about
this famous leftist ceo named dan price
he's famous because he raised everyone's
salaries to 70 000 and it caused a lot
of issues but also garnered a lot of
attention among the left he is now being
accused of some very serious
let's just say mitu he's been metoo'd
and uh he's been forced to resign
and so there's this meme this old meme
called reset the clock
and that was whenever a male feminist
was outed as being a predator you'd
reset the clock here we go again
so the new york times reported on this
we'll talk about that but we got a bunch
of other stories and i'm really excited
to talk about she-hulk
yes it's right a marvel show cause you
guys know i love marvel shows but this
this clip is going viral where the
she-hulk talks about how she has to
control her anger over men cat calling
her and when incompetent men tell her
how to do her job
i have a lot to say about this but it's
going viral i think i think ben shapiro
may have talked about it as well it is
uh it's it's become a cultural debate
and i actually watched she-hulk later
not actually mostly liked it but i gotta
call out this segment we gotta talk
about that before we get started and of
course the peter teal stuff before we
get started head over to timcast.com
become a member support our work you'll
get access to all of our shows we got
the tim cast uncensored after after hour
show monday through thursday cass castle
vlogs are officially live they'll be up
every tuesday at 7 p.m a mix of behind
the scenes fun hanging out and silly
comedy tales from inverted world of
course is in its second season with new
episodes sunday at 10 am right that's
right 10 am
and then of course you got pop culture
christ chicken city smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show if you really do like it
joining us to talk about this and more
we got will chamberlain
thank you uh senior counsel at the
internet accountability project the
article 3 project um
really happy to be here as always i
don't know i must have be coming up on
like seven or eight appearances oh yeah
yeah
we were um
i don't want to say who who our guest
was supposed to be because we're hoping
to rebook them but we are going to get a
very high ranking official from the
trump administration who unfortunately
had to cancel on us and we needed will's
legal expertise but of course will is
still here with a lot of stuff to talk
about so i'm really excited for that
thanks for hanging out friend we got
shane cashman what's up thanks for
having me guys uh author and host of
tales from the inverted world at
timcast.com exclusive and uh yeah every
sunday at 10 right now we're doing
ghosts from the civil war
and watching me have my life threatened
and uh
twice right
twice yeah and uh it's been a crazy year
and uh we're gonna be launching the
inverted world podcast which is the
conversations with people and their
weird experiences ufos yeah having
guests and stuff and you guys can call
in
yeah call in stories i'm really excited
for that because there's like an endless
number of people telling crazy stories
that need to get exposure yeah you know
like i've heard like there's there i
don't i don't know if i should reveal
any of the stories that you've already
been working on
some of this like people have been
talking about jumping dimensions and
weird stuff alternate husbands alternate
husbands
missing husbands you know the hadron
collider gets turned on and then a new
husband might have showed up dude these
stories are crazy yeah
just before the show we were talking
about like cia advanced weaponry and
stuff like that
so i think this is going to be a real
fun conversation
yeah yeah thanks for having me ian's
hanging out hi everybody ian crossland
musician entertainer actor and internet
video pioneer billboard model that's
right philanthropist billionaire playboy
all of the above and
crooked camera wow
someone bumped him who who did that who
did it who did he done it
what's up everybody happy friday
let's get down to brass tacks hello half
of ian oh good we figured if you can get
my whole name in the side that's yeah
that's what i like to do for the first
frame
friday we're always just like eyes half
glazed over and just like ready to go
got a little whiskey yeah whiskey all
right did you already introduce yourself
i am also here i'm wearing my friday
t-shirt because we are just chilling
with our two regulars love these two
guys let's get going
all right we're going to jump to this
first story and it's from the new york
times but we will be leading with a
quote from dan price posting on linkedin
he said
in the unlikely event that you are
falsely accused remember that will be
much easier for you to overcome false
allegations than it will be for actual
victims to overcome the trauma of
harassment or assault go on uh that
being said dan
i suppose i'm not supposed to care at
all that you are claiming these are
false allegations but these are some
crazy allegations so take a look at the
headline
social media was a ceo's bullhorn and
how he lured women oh my gosh this is
what you get when you pander to woke
people or maybe the people who pander to
these woke people are just predators
dan price was applauded for paying a
minimum salary of 70 thousand dollars at
his seattle company and criticizing
corporate greed the adulation helped to
hide and enable his behavior
i'm just going to give you the gist of
it yo this is crazy like they talk about
how he's on the daily show and they did
magazines with him but apparently he's
been accused um
i guess of like drugging a woman look at
this raping and drug drugging a victim
on monday police in palm springs
california said they had referred ms
marges's case to local prosecutors
recommending a charge of rape of a
drugged victim
prosecutors in seattle earlier this year
charged with a price with assault and
another incident apparently tried to
kiss a woman and then when she refused
he choked her
so questions
is this retaliation from the woke
because you can never trust them or is
it that if someone is willing to pander
and lie to gain power they're probably
willing to do that for sex
yeah and there's there's sort of a
a default like the the fakeness of nice
like i actually distinguish between
being nice and being kind
right like kindness is something that
comes from a position of like strength
and normalcy nice whenever you talk
about nice guys you always know that
there's like an element of like
deception nefariousness right like it's
sort of like i think that people think
that they put coins in the nice it's
like a like a vending machine right they
put coins in the nice button and then
eventually they get to the girl they
want like a nice guy won't step on
someone's toes a kind guy might step on
your toes just to let you know your toes
are in the wrong spot yeah or like well
it kind of does it for kind of just does
it from a position of strength right
like they have the ability to do to they
could be they have powers so but they're
being kind and not using it that way
we're as nice as like
they're like they're trying to attract
women by being
like fake and they're like they think
it's a game yeah
i knew i knew a guy
me and my me me and this other guy we
were hanging out my one friend is like
you know rico suave type who's going to
bars and picking up chicks and like very
proud of himself
and this other guy was having trouble
so i'm sitting there and i'm kind of
like passively listening
and there's we'll call him guy a because
i don't want to
call anybody's personal lives out but
guy a is talking about how
he doesn't understand why he's always in
the friend zone he goes on to so so you
know guy b who's this suave dude is like
tell me what you do when you go on a
date and he explained how he he's like i
always put women i always treat them
like royalty like queens i ask them
whatever they want you can have
and then we i i'm listening to this and
i was just like dude you think that
comes off as sincere and nice
like it you're treating the person like
they're not really there with you you're
acting like they're a piece of plastic
and that you're going to feed the
machine quarters hoping that sex comes
out i was like that's not what being
like that's not nice that's creepy yeah
and also breeds resentment right like
then they feel because they have put in
the nice coins and they don't get what
they're expecting they get super
resentful and angry about it it's like
the kind of guy who there's like a woman
and she's got spinach in her teeth and
he's like i'm not gonna say exactly what
i was thinking about the hottest girl in
the world if she got spinach and teeth
tell her she she wants to know this so
she can take it out right but that's
anybody too like nice and kind it's like
if someone had gunk in their teeth would
you tell them i do yeah i'm like hey you
got a thing in your teeth yeah and they
go oh thanks they'll be more mad at you
if you didn't tell them right and then
they find out they're like why didn't
you tell me because like oh i don't want
to put you on the spot i don't want to
no so so this guy dan price i really
want to talk about his business because
so much of what we see coming from
perceive this really really grinds my
gears the idea of left versus right if
you are a sincere person who asks a
question you're right-wing
i'll give you i'll give you an example
right
uh sheamus this is one of sheamus jokes
he says
the left will come out and be like we
want good thing we want good thing and
then a conservative will go
okay
how should how do we pay for a good
thing you want bad thing you want bad
things
and that's like the whole it's like your
right wing for simply being like
so we get the story of this guy dan
price he raises everybody's salary well
i happen to run a company and i
understand how taxes work so my first
question here
he lowers his salary from like a million
bucks or something to 70 thousand
and for me alarm bells went off i was
like oh bro's trying to save himself
some money because it's it's when when
uh
when you take profit versus uh
like compensation it's their tax
differently and so or this is at least
how two of my two different accounting
companies i've gone with have explained
it to me so
you know maybe they're not correct but
this is my understanding is that passive
uh profit is not taxed the same way as
employment income or compensate direct
compensation so when i see this i'm like
if the dude lowers his salary he's going
to save a lot of money in taxes right
that's assuming if he owns or has a
major stake in the company right he's
running right and i'm pretty sure this
dude he's assistant yeah he does right
yeah he gets profit
so at the end of the year if you're only
paying yourself 70k like bezos does this
bezos takes an 87 000 a year salary and
then gets bonuses
and then
justify the irs why your salary is so
low but if you're going to get audited
anyway so what i was told by uh two
different accounting companies was if
you're a ceo of a company with you know
like an eight-figure revenue and then
you pay yourself something like 70k yo
you're gonna get audited in two seconds
because they're like that's that's bull
that's bull you're trying to not pay
your employment taxes
so when i saw this i was like well how
would how would you get around that it's
ideological now if they come to you and
be like hey man that's not it at all i
believe in fair wages for all people and
i shouldn't be making that much money in
a salary
but in profits a different question
right so i don't know if how much money
he actually saved by doing it he did
raise the salaries of everybody in his
company became a big star over it
surprise surprise the dude's being
accused
again i think there's a strong
possibility it's false accusation i'm
not i'm not gonna assume it's these are
real claims just because the guy happens
to be on the left yeah all the raises he
made are kind of goes back to what will
is saying about kind versus nice because
the raises could have just been the
veneer of nice of kindness right but
it's really just a nefarious niceness
right and now it's blowing up in his
face i feel like that's so much of what
the left is i mean i think this is what
most people kind of feel
that it's performative grifting
you know
maybe he did something good it's like
all right you know yeah but what was
like and and i have to say this about
trump too
is the reasoning behind it that
important if they're actively doing
something good
because we have to speculate as to his
reasoning but i think it's great that
he's paying his staff more money
i got an article from geekwire about
this story he made according to
you know whatever the documents that he
made 950 000 in
2010 900 000 in 2011 but then when he
went on tv told him he made 50 000 in
2011 when he actually made 900 000.
uh this was on
january and then this was uh with cnbc
kelly evans is when he told her i made
probably 50 000 then he later came out i
was like oh i misspoke
so i don't know if this guy's a hundred
thousand dollars he's just he's just a
creep he's like he's a classic male
feminist right like literally arc tipple
male feminist
you know using
uh like woke politics and like bs
because he thinks that's what women want
to hear and then when they say no
all of a sudden the fangs come out dude
he if he actually made 900 000 and told
someone that he made 50 000. that's
insanity he's a psychotic person like
is he misleading he's like my salary was
only but he knows in the back of his
mind he made 900 000 in profit uh it's
really disturbing that he made that and
he was like let this be the last lie i
ever tell apparently apparently there
was a guy for me apparently there were
big problems when he did this too
so like what happened was these are just
stories that i heard
there were some employees that were
making 70k a year because they were like
an accounts manager and then there are
some people who are in the mail room who
are getting hourly pay all of a sudden
these mail room people got bumped up to
the same salaries and accounts manager
who saw no raise
and then they were just like i've been
here for how long and you gave them a 50
000 a year raising i got nothing
and so i read you know it's been a long
time it could be wrong but a bunch of
people resigned saying like it's deeply
offensive that we would not receive more
compensation
but like the idea of of a minimum wage
meant they got nothing and the people of
lower skill and lower time at the
company lower seniority got massive like
two or three hundred percent raises yeah
i would actually be furious right like
it's a complete stunt if you're one of
those people making like 70 80k for a
job that you know requires a college
degree and you have debts and things
like that and then he like bumps up like
the the you know intern or whatever or
the entry level job up to 70 and you're
like where's my race that's cool the
argument was supposed to be that's like
you shouldn't be mad that someone else
is making more money that's what a lot
the left was saying like what it's not
affecting you at all and it's like you
got to understand man
when your company takes money from the
budget and gives a raise to everyone but
you that is like getting punched in the
gut mm-hmm that's crazy and so the idea
but it's raised to a minimum it's like
yeah but like to hear that a co-worker
got a 500 or 300 raise and you got a
zero it's not about 70k it's not about a
minimum it's about you working hard and
hoping to make more money to live a
better life and he's not doing that for
you
but everybody else you are now it's
almost like they got pushed to the
minimum so people resigned you know
apparently but hey look man i i don't
care how he runs his business you know
he can do whatever he wants
congratulations he found a way to get a
bunch of attention make a bunch of money
yeah don't be a predator though that
seemed pretty yeah you know it's a good
take away yeah maybe maybe definitely i
object first and foremost to the
predation
right it's like
right like it's here here it's like that
nor mcdonald joke it's like you know the
worst thing about bill cos somebody's
like saying the worst thing about bill
cosby is hypocrisy and he's like no i
thought the worst thing about bill cosby
was you know the crimes
yeah
yeah that's a thing man so
you know when i look at what there's a
guy in here seven years running the
marketing company
well this guy this guy wait i don't know
yeah both they're both okay it's a new
man
yeah so like when i see people like uh
dan price i i'm actually kind of like
okay you know like do you think man like
i'm not going to complain about a guy
how he runs his business if he's getting
attention for raising salaries it's like
whatever dude i don't trust it but i'm
not here to rag on that you know what i
mean if somebody wants to
do their business that way it's you know
just far be it for me you know but the
surprise surprise you know i mean like
drug raping a drugged victim is a crazy
thing to be accused of now i'll say this
too innocent until proven guilty always
because i think i think it could be
false i mean look
you're a powerful white man
and you enter the woke fray to exploit
it i wonder if some of this stuff is
they know he's grifting off them so they
destroy him you know like not just his
story but other stories where they're
like
as a possibility it also may just be
dude imagine being like
made of
cheese
and then deciding to walk into a room
full of mice you know what i mean like
like imagine being a banana and walking
to a monkey sanctuary look i'm just
gonna go with his advice i don't want to
inflict trauma on his victims
i'm just gonna i'm just going to believe
his accuser will then leave it at that
that's such a sense of hubris to be like
i got this i'll be fine i'm a white guy
but i can i got this in the bag as long
as i hand her to them i'll be safe here
they should know though that so many
heroes that they prop up they eventually
it's like the new hero's journey they
end up falling they end up devouring
themselves in the end whether they did
it or not it's like yeah you know louis
c.k was one of them and a lot of people
whether it was true or not who i can't
it's crazy
you know so we use parallel economy for
tim cast and this is co-founded by dan
bongino it's censorship resistance why
would i
use a company that hates me it's like
you're the ceo of this company and
you're like i know let's append to the
people who explicitly hate me based on
my race and my gender and that's a good
business move that seems like really
dumb it seems yeah very fragile based in
fear
desperation tactic if you were to do
something like that that'd be like using
your slave owners weapons to break out
of slavery or something right i don't
know but they only do that because
that's their only option if you have
another option you you use the company
that you have
i really want to talk about feminism
right now oh yeah
okay me
[Laughter]
oh too right you guys ready for this one
sure get we'll go broke imdb tweets ahem
say it louder for the people in the back
she-hulk tatiana miss laney
you guys ready for this clip from the
it's from tiktok but it's she-hulk
listen to this
here's the thing bruce i'm great at
controlling my anger i do it all the
time
when i'm catcalled in the street
when incompetent men explain my own area
of expertise to me i do it
pretty much every day because if i don't
i will get called
emotional or difficult or
might just literally get murdered so i'm
an expert at controlling my anger
because i do it infinitely more than you
i love this clip for this face right
here
he's like
a new male feminist all right all right
spoiler alerts i don't know how many of
you wanted to watch she-hulk but i do i
like i love watching the marvel stuff
even though it like i didn't watch um
i i did watch a bit of miss marvel and
it was
awful it was just so awful so uh but
we'll get to that a second so uh this
clip's great it's really really great
because as much as people are like
mocking the clip
it is masterfully done it is a work of
art
it is it is so perfect that i was i was
excited to see it
and the reason is
minutes
before this scene
she is outside of a bar we watched it
before the show i guess explain to you
guys and three guys
are not even hollering not even cat
calling like
i we were shane i was asking chad like
is this hot so the guys come out and
they're like hey what's your name and
she goes i'm i'm waiting for someone and
it's like well let us keep you company
because my boyfriend's going to be here
and he's like oh come on we're just
being friendly she goes
hold us out and then gets ready to
murder the dudes she like winds up and
then hulk stops her from doing it
and so i was i was actually asking shane
i was like was that was that even
hollering like cat calling is when
you're like saying crude things below
that
it's below that it's working up to a
pickup line but you're not worried about
that it wasn't even hollering hollering
bang likes up girl why don't you come
over here they were just like what's
your name like let us keep you company
and i'm like it's it's almost hollering
so this is a parable about why women
shouldn't have power yeah perhaps
perhaps
but this is why i think
look
at that the clip is perfect here we go
we got it the clip is perfect she almost
murdered these dudes she winds up for
like a kick and we know from the show
because they show her throwing boulders
and smashing a cliff with their fists
that a full force kick would have
exploded these men
here's what else we learn
in the show
when she hulks out with bruce
he tries to calm her down and he's like
calm calm and she goes why are you
talking to me like a child and he goes
wait a minute
you're you're in there and she goes yes
and you learn
that when bruce goes hulk he loses his
mind he becomes a rage monster when she
transforms she's fully cognitive and
lucid of what she's doing which means
when she's sitting there explaining to
him
that
she can control her anger she's lying
she's also a dangerous violent
psychopath and
immediately after this she says i
control my anger every day and then she
holds out
and then she calms back down
and so not only
is she lying about controlling her anger
in two instances here
she's she's she's lying like
it's the perfect example of feminism
exaggerating the claim
lying about their ability to control it
and then justifying that as why they're
a victim brilliant if they say
misogyny like this entire program is
just like secretly
putting forward like actually
yeah if you if you like i'm watching
this and i i see this clip going around
and they're like say it for everyone in
back and i'm like yeah but the context
of it is that she's lying like it's like
three minutes before she says that she
tries to murder some dude
and she's she's lucid she's aware she's
doing it
i'm like that's feminism
nailed it
and they if they define any type of
word as violence then you can match that
with violence so even them just
approaching them saying hey what's up
that's violence i i i dude i really love
this show already
uh she hulk's the villain
she's the bad guys
uh so i'll tell you something else i
just it's just it's really good um in
spiderman why do we like spider-man with
great power comes great responsibility
man what a message for a little kid
especially for those of us who want
people to grow up to be responsible
regardless of who they are what they do
take some personal responsibility the
story of spider-man
you know if we if we'll use the movie
reference he does the wrestling match
the dude refuses to pay him then the guy
comes in and steals the money and as the
burglar is running away the guy's like
stop that man and spider-man's like
i don't see that's my problem but then
that guy is running away
is tries to steal a car and he rob and
he robs uncle ben and shoots and kills
him and then spider-man is like if i
just stop the guy and took
responsibility for my community my uncle
would have lived and it's like a very
sad message in this
hulk desperately begs her to use her
powers for good and she outright refuses
and says no it's my life and i'm gonna
follow my career and he says there's
very few people who have the power we do
the ability to protect this planet you
have to do it she goes no i don't she
beats the crap out of hulk destroys his
bar
it actually is a funny scene and then
they rebuild it together and she goes
i'm leaving he goes fine if you want to
just be a small time lawyer like i
respect that she's like okay and then
she leaves
the point of the show is that she is not
she is refusing responsibility for her
powers i'm just like it's like what
you're saying will if the real message
was to insult feminism they nailed it
right yeah like that's what that sounds
like it sounds like kind of a
stealth you know refutation of it
basically a critique of feminism is
deeply selfish right yeah
the hulk originally was like a chaotic
evil creature that was inside of bruce
banner who was like a new he was like a
neutral good guy so it was destructive
and and unex um unpredictable so i think
they've infused the uh
chaotic evil character into the woman's
psyche inadvertently making her chaotic
evil
you're saying hulk was kind of evil yeah
bruce banner would turn into this
chaotic evil
demon yeah basically the whole chaotic
neutral right yeah hulk was
destructively evil and dangerous what
are you talking about he lived off of he
was a rage monster yeah yeah but he was
he like he's he was the protagonist so
that was the cool thing about it was he
was an evil he's not a protagonist he
wasn't evil well the hulk itself was an
evil creature that they had to keep
everyone wanted to stop it whenever it
would go so he was always trying to stop
it from appearing but he it would do it
wasn't it was like the hulk was just
amoral rage right like it was just he
would do good things he would do bad
things
anger isn't really anymore i think anger
is is definitely a moral the anger you
can be angry and injustice or you can be
angry at things just be angry like
someone kicked my leg on accident
break
but think about that for a second you're
saying that a lawful good person can't
be enraged because that would make them
well that was the interesting thing
about hawkins he was two people he bruce
banner is like a good person and then
the hulk was this evil thing that would
come out of him and he'd be like no i
got to stop it but hulk wasn't evil he
was an avenger the very original hulk
was like this evil demon with no
personnel it was just a rage monster and
then they kind of started to craft him
and give him a personality a hero or
something yeah yeah yeah okay that makes
sense like because yeah i'm not really
deeply familiar with
like the universe so i've like i saw the
avengers you know
yeah but eventually they gave they made
bruce the hulk one person that's my
favorite version of the hulk is when he
has a mind and he's like buddhist yeah
yeah
chilling um i have some technical
problems with this show i haven't seen
it yet but when she in the beginning of
the scene she starts to tell him this
emotional thing and looks away to the
right as she's talking that's really
annoying to watch actors do that it's
kind of there they see her look to the
right it's like she's trying to generate
fake emotion which she glances to the
right right there it's really annoying
like you need a director to be like no
look him in the eyes when you're talking
well she's not looking at anybody's eyes
she's supposed to be looking at bruce's
eyes no but like she's actually looking
at a big axe on a stick she might have
bruce in front of him working they might
be working the scene she asked her she
has to look up which means they would
have bruce and he would have a stick
coming off his back with like a circle a
green circle on it and she has to look
at the two dots on the green circle so
she dropped the ball there and then at
the end whoever wrote this this guy's
just ragging on the acting
she says i feel anger infinitely more
than you infinite is not a multiplier
you can't multiply something by infinite
it's that's a zero so it makes no sense
an illogical statement is very of course
ian has an issue with the semantics of
the statement yeah the lighting is good
though
the lighting's pretty good so hulk's
like her mentor throughout this is that
the deal well he like kidnaps her or
kidnaps her oh no
she almost murdered a dude right and so
hulk thinks it's because she's that's
gonna be dan price's defense
yeah yeah imagine him hitting on her
sorry i had i had to choke her your
honor paul thought that she was a rage
monster like he was right
yeah i'm surprised he finds out like
good writing would have been him being
like wait a minute you're conscious
right now it's like yes and he would
have been like that means you tried to
murder those guys yeah like yo that's
that's crazy different discussion then
she just uh she just goes back to being
a lawyer it's like first of all you know
i said she was the villain right i mean
she's a lawyer come on you know how much
more villainous can you get they need to
make her selfish too
i'm saying that cause will's here
what percentage of lawyers do you think
are good
oh i mean most of them honestly
like most like 51 percent i don't know
what's like
most lawyers are you know trying to do a
good trying to do good work and serve
their clients like now they're gonna
maybe they're in a position where their
clients are people you might find
distasteful like you don't but you don't
get to pick your clients if you're like
a big law firm for example you know i
mean i could have for example like i had
the choice well i i had some choices but
my choices were between uh bill cosby
when i was working in big law and uh
there was a guy who had a dirty money
episode made after him for running a um
a like payday lending scheme
that the ftc sued them for a billion
dollars over
so like that that's what those are the
clients who represent those clients if
you work at a big law firm like and it's
it's okay to not like those people but
like i hate when people attack the
lawyers for defending those people and
moreover it's like they're they're dead
that is your job right i think i don't
know if you guys watch better call saul
if you don't you should excellent show
um but one of the one of the big themes
in one of the later seasons is how you
know one of the protagonists lawyers is
representing a bank client and then is
also kind of like screwing over that
client to help the little guys who the
bank is adverse to and it's like there's
like there's a bad lawyer that's a bad
lawyer exactly and that's sort of the
point that the show is making is it's
like it's giving you first it kind of
gives you the reason to sympathize with
the lawyer and be like oh yeah you know
she's working and trying to you know be
robin hood here but you the longer it
goes on the more you realize like no no
she's actually doing she's the bad
person here yeah because she is
betraying her client and like she
eventually you know has to leave her
firm and all that i know there's a bunch
of jokes about lawyers like i literally
made one there's there's one i can't
remember but it's like a guy goes to
hell and then he's like
you know it's like a guy sells a soul to
the devil and then he goes to hell and
he's like i need a lawyer and then
everyone raises their hand or whatever
the joke is i don't know but i actually
think most lawyers are good i actually
think the overall majority in my
interactions i have not actually uh
experienced the stereotype of a bad
lawyer
yeah i mean most of them are doing their
jobs and and trying to help their
clients they're expensive because
there's a cartel yeah that's one reason
and then they're i mean the worst sense
to get the to get barred and all that
stuff right yeah no i mean law school is
expensive it's not just getting bored
right you have to go to law school being
good it's you know costs money is that
the cartel is that you got to go to the
expense of gotta go to law school and
then pass a bar exam right like you have
and both are usually a requirement in
most states so that that's what you know
i mean people come out of law school 150
grand in debt and they put in three
years of work so it's like the the
starting
pay to just even hire a lawyer is is
really high not kim kardashian though in
california you don't need no bar well i
mean
in california you don't need to go to
law school and i'm pretty sure kim
kardashian went to law school okay like
you know yeah yeah that's good so yeah
but like yeah california has its own
weird thing where you can like not go to
law school but pass the bar exam or you
can go to a non-accredited law school
it's kind of crazy how like you go to
law school to try and become like
proficient but then you realize having a
big butt makes you more money you know
it's true it's a plus yeah
so it's it's crazy like on instagram
there's like i don't want to i don't
want to call anybody out cause i'm like
but there's like these women
who have they they let's say they do
specific talents
like they sing or they they're skiers or
snowboarders
and then it's like i'll see the video of
you know them doing their skill but then
every other video is like you know busty
cleavage showing or like booty shaking
and stuff like that and those are the
ones that get most the views and it's
like well duh you know what i mean i
wonder what's the point of even doing
the other
videos if like in the end you realize
like where the i'll tell you i'll tell
you a better story
there was this uh woman on youtube this
is like six years ago i was at youtube i
was talking with google people about
this
she played guitar and she sang
her videos would get a few thousand
views if you go into her library you'd
see one day she went from like 2000 to
like 200 000 on her video views and it
was amazing it's like wow she had her
big break she must have put out a really
good song
you know what the big difference was
between the video before with low views
and the video high with many views
cleavage cleavage
she started she started wearing like
like bathing suit tops with her boobs on
her guitar as she played and then the
views went through the roof i find it
unfortunate that the sex appeal has
become a gateway drug to the the true
passion of these people but it but it
works because they know they tap into it
the second you post some cleavage then
they they get more views i wonder if it
matters i'm going to try it tomorrow
like like
adele i'm going to try right now
adele did not get big and famous
through like trying to be this sexy
she's a big girl yeah i mean she lost a
lot of weight yeah but she just made
really great music and that worked i'm
like
i i i genuinely don't know do these
women feel like lesser because it's not
the skill or talent that that got them
there it's the sex appeal or does it
matter it might be the competition on
social media because it's like when
people are mad at certain pop stars like
um like miley cyrus or billy eilish when
they start out as one thing and then
they mutate into the sexy thing i think
it's the the industry might be
pressuring them it could be social media
but it you know people hate it or they
love it because their their kids who
might have been with hannah montana are
now with you know i mean twerking you
got to wonder like you look at the
kardashians and like do they care i mean
like isn't what i don't know which one's
the billionaire one like kylie or
whatever
one of one kylie jenner yeah kylie
jenner's i think there's multiple
billionaires in the yeah i think but i
think kim is you might all be
like i think she's like the youngest
billionaire yeah kylie jenner is like
the youngest bill yeah yeah yeah like do
you think she cares that people are
gonna be like you got famous off your
ass they're gonna be like she's gonna be
like
i mean
her sister got famous with a sex tape
right like like relative to her family
like she's like i was pretty
conservative but you know the other
thing too is like um i was reading about
i think it's kylie i don't know a lot
about the generous but uh
it's not just sex appeal that got her to
be a billionaire like it's it's legit
business i think they're also really
smart they're super sure yes that's what
i say like kim went to law school or
whatever she got mentored i think is
what it is in california you can be
mentored but not go to law school but
still have to pass the bar right like i
don't i don't think i don't think but i
don't know you'd have to look it up if
california actually has any requirement
about taking about going to law school
right to be barred almost every other
state does that makes sense for
california i mean it's
i think
probably it's risky right like the but
one the bar exam's not that hard okay uh
frankly and then two like there's a lot
that you actually learn in the first
year or two of law school the third
year's bs and it's like that's what
we've all seen legally blonde yeah well
we get it
what's in the third year uh the third
year is like a bunch of electives that
you don't need to take
like basically and it's a way for the
law school to make a little extra money
off you like really the first two years
or what not
sounds like the lawyer should overtake
that and just chop it down to two years
well the lawyers don't care once they've
graduated because right it's keeping
prices the prices are already high and
they're you know they're making money
it's just like once you're in the cartel
you don't have a reason to lower the bar
and make it easier for other people to
become aware my my experience with like
getting cast for the the way you look is
really an empty like it's a i felt lousy
whenever i was in hollywood doing it if
i got like a modeling job and they take
pictures i'd be like i just feel empty
afterwards and like especially when they
start saying it and they're like we just
want to promote your sex appeal ian
you're so sexual i want your sex i'm
like god this this industry is missing
the mark man you want good
good acting good acting first it's like
is that's not a joke like you you you
got modeling jobs yeah yeah i did he's
in a suit
more than one super bowl commercial i
was in one super bowl commercial it was
uh orbit gum commercial okay um i did
commercials did a couple of one tv show
aliens in america did the pilot of that
show that was pretty fun we launched
that and then i did a little bit of
photography uh modeling stuff but is
there not a painting downstairs of you
ripped
yeah
we should bring it up here
the abs are too much and i think an
example of the emptiness as you see in
the cosmetic surgery that they
i i'm looking at it right now is this uh
kylie jenner has a cosmetic company so
it's like cosmetic the way you look of
course the way you look that's right
that's right that's the way she
monetizes her instagram is makeup i
don't know
that i in my experience leads to
emptiness on the inside but you know
it's a lot of money so you kind of just
pretend like it's okay and well my my
problem with
so as much as like
in the culture war they would call me
right wing i'm like
particularly left especially when it
comes to these ultra wealthy people who
use their money and just keep amassing
and hoarding and amassing and hoarding
and they're not doing anything
that that bums me out i'm also fair
libertarian so i'm like i'm not going to
rag on them and force them to do
anything with their money i just kind of
accept the fact that people make money
and then they do whatever they want with
it it's like okay well i wish they would
do more yeah the problem is
maybe it's better we're better off they
don't because mackenzie bezos decided to
do more with jeff's money and then she
funded a whole bunch of woke garbage so
it's kind of like maybe we'd be better
off if she bought a yacht with an
infinity pool instead of funding woke
racist bs right just as useless
like employ some people right like have
yeah well the card one kardashian kim
has a company where it's like um
like underwear and stuff like that and
i've heard from a lot of different
people that they love it like it's
actually really good and she's got a lot
of people she employs so yeah they're
doing something and it's not i don't
want to knock on just a sex appeal
because they are some of the ones that
are the always knocked on for how they
look but they're doing something it's
funny because people would always say
like the kardashians are famous for
being famous and it's like you realize
that means they're like some of the best
marketers on the planet and that's it
yeah they're really good at it well i i
think they had actually a very strong
family life is is you could say as
unconventional as with bruce becoming
caitlyn but like as i from what i was
told bruce was a fantastic father like a
stepfather to these girls and um their
mom is a brilliant woman like if you
have i've only seen the show in passing
my mom is a big fan of the show actually
which was really weird because she
doesn't watch that stuff at all she's
like they're actually really really
smart people interesting yeah i think
they're really good at shaping reality
like i can never say how they really are
a family but they're good at making it
look like they're good at family yeah
like trump like trump like it's all it's
all just a facade oh man trump endorsing
those democrats was
and then you saw that that woman took
the bait
right yulin uh neo is running against
goldman and then i think that's dan
goldman right yeah and then she was like
trump just endorsed my opponent and then
people were like why and she's like
because he's trying to stop the left and
it's like dude she knows it's a but
she's like
unless these people are really that daft
man but uh you know
where would we be without trump like
this would be a very boring reality we
would have hillary clinton we probably
hillary would probably still be the
president
um libya for sure so we probably have
invaded and had forces in syria yeah um
wars everywhere the russian thing i
don't know the ukraine thing would
probably still be happening we wouldn't
be talking about politics that's what we
wouldn't be this wouldn't be a politics
show if you were doing it still if trump
wasn't here if trump hadn't been elected
politics would have been so boring and
depressing oh right right right like
because it would have been back to you
know 2012 era uniparty like
it with this
i disagree to a certain degree
we wouldn't be talking about electoral
politics so much we'd be talking about
conflict crisis war and things like that
because that's what i was involved with
you know covering uh more grassroots
activism stuff more cultural stuff so
we'd probably be talking
i'll put it this way
the woke stuff would have been ramped up
way faster
uh we would have
i look i i don't know exactly what would
have happened with the pandemic but
would have been way more extreme way
harsher so i think politics would have
happened to a certain degree no matter
what
but it would be like you said very
uniparty establishment and it would not
be pop culture so this show would
probably exist we'd probably talk about
it probably a lot smaller
yeah like i mean it would just be much
more depressing because i remember
i don't know if you felt this way but
politics and like from during the obama
era was depressing and it's not just
because like obama was like bad or
horrible it was because there was no
distinction between him and romney i
guess you guys remember the debates
between obama and romney no if well
there's at some point like a little bit
there was a foreign policy debate it was
the last debate of that presidential
election i remember it distinctly
because i remember posting something
like i have a mormon drinking game and
the drinking game is uh drink whenever
they articulate a difference on foreign
policy right like you would just you'd
stay sober
it was like
it was a debate where mitt romney did
not disagree with anything obama said
for an hour and a half they both agreed
about uh bringing jobs back well the
economy stuff is where romney tried to
distinguish himself and did an okay job
in that second debate it was the one
where he's like oh i approve of what
you're doing in libya
that's a great idea oh i approve of this
in syria yeah you're exactly right about
the red line interesting is this after
the dog being on the car yeah
um so yeah it just would have been so
boring and
i mean i think you know i'm glad we had
trump for that reason because now we
really have two different parties i've
been thinking about ukraine a lot i want
to know what you guys think about this
is like right now what it looks like is
that the american british french have
like troops in ukraine on the front of
russia it'd be like if russia had
troops all along the western coast of
california and blockaded all the sea
access because basically ukraine's
blocking russia's access to the black
sea so like if all of
i don't know um let's just say mexico
and the gulf yeah yeah or if they put a
bunch of troops you know on the rio on
the rio grande and then started blocking
our access to the gulf or something like
that yeah yeah but it's like we'd have
all of california except a very thin
strip of land along the coast that we
had no coastal access it would be no one
would stand for that it would be insane
but a better way to put is if russia uh
started putting troops in mexico and
canada or alaska on our border so this
is the crazy thing you guys saw that
video of the of uh what's it marin the
finnish prime minister yeah yeah party
and she's like shaking it and bouncing
it and all that stuff
you know look i don't care if someone
wants to party but as the prime minister
when you are facing
nuclear deployment by russia
for joining nato and you are on the
border of this country
and that's your prime minister
like i got no problem with people want
to dance have a good time i do have an
issue with having a world leader who is
acting more like a 16 year old
girl yeah come on
the thing is that you're a 40 year old i
think it's a function of the fact that
the eu has basically like swamped the
major functions of most of these
sovereigns and so right you end up with
this very like ridiculous you get enough
with some ridiculous leaders in some of
these countries and you compare that
actually this is a weird analogy finland
is a vassal state for the yeah you know
israel something about israel is really
interesting
if you actually look at the pictures of
their politicians and their leaders
they're
smiling ever smiling they're very
right
never
serious they're very very serious
because that's sort of like that's the
political yeah israel like you're
constantly defending against a bunch of
crimes you're surrounding you like and
you look at american politicians
complete reverse right american
politicians are always smiling in their
profile have you ever looked at like the
evolution of the smile and presidential
portraits no over the years it's really
fun i forget where it turns the george
washington frump yeah yeah
there is an owned dude there's a
distinct moment where where presidents
start to smile i forget where that is it
might be around nixon or something and
then it's full on big smile you know we
need we need trump when he wins in 2025
to just go like
full grimace like
right right dark maggot
i'm not a big i mean i definitely don't
support invasion uh russia's invasion of
ukraine i'm not a big but i'm i
understand why they did and i think it's
purely to have sea access because if
russia had blocked off alaskan western
all the coast and just that was russia
and we couldn't get boats out it would
be come on you don't even have a state
if you don't have the sea access you are
correct
the black sea is their only warm water
port they use that for access to the
mediterranean uh the reason why syria is
an important allies because they have
the military base in tartus so the
actions the us was taking to put a
pipeline through syria and opposing the
the assad regime was a direct threat to
russia's naval base then with the with
ukraine wanting to go towards uh the e
towards the eu so this is really
interesting man the the politics are are
really interesting the the the eu
offered them money with contingencies
russia offered them money with different
contingencies russia seems to have
according to some arguments a kind of
better deal but ukrainians don't like
russia for a very obvious reason you
know what that reason is it's the hall
of demore
and so when i went there and talked to
people they said even if the deal is not
as good with the eu we get we want
schengen's own access so this seems
better for us yeah
this was a huge threat to russia because
they knew they would lose crimea where
they had a base and their only access to
the warm water the black sea warm water
port so of course russia then goes in
and basically takes crimea
the west at the time was very
much in favor of the ongoing revolution
or whatever you want to call it the the
revolt against yanukovych russia viewed
that as
to to the outside world in the news it
was a protest it was people protesting
and declaring a new government in
reality it was nato influence eu
influence versus the russian the
expansion of russia and their desire for
a trade federation some say putin wanted
to bring back the soviet union in some
capacity or just outright so this has
always been a deeper political conflict
that's bubbling up to war
except for when donald trump got elected
and everything started to simmer down
and calm down
isis was defeated
things started to stabilize a bit in the
middle east it wasn't all perfect i mean
there was missile strikes in assyria
yeah the saudi arabian yemen but russia
was backing off until joe biden comes
back and then russia ramps everything
back up because putin knew
joe biden in the uniparty regime the
establishment was going to try and
destabilize the region and gain more
power control and expand
the crazy thing about nato its purpose
is resisting the soviet union the soviet
union doesn't exist anymore you have the
remnants in russia but nato keeps
expanding it is a rapid military
expansion now taking in sweden and
finland and that is whether you like it
or not whether it's good or bad for
america a direct threat to many
countries in that region and and if
you're worried if you look at the
expansion of the soviet union if you
look at the expansion into vietnam this
is one of the reasons the us want to get
involved stop the communist expansion
the korean war we understand why
militaristic expansion is a bad thing
once the soviets collapse the u.s ramps
it up
when there's no direct threat of course
russia is going to lose their mind now
you got china doing these joint military
drills and i'll tell you man people like
biden
i i think they revel in it i think they
want it
i think their their attitude is you know
it's like that famous story about the
napoleonic wars
someone ran you know horseback to
england and said napoleon won the stocks
all collapsed and they bought it all up
and they're like actually he lost and
then the stocks spiked back up and now
they bought them all again catastrophe
is great for people who want to exploit
the crisis it's great for the war
machine i think they know it i think
they're thinking oil profits more
control more access more expansion be
damned whoever gets killed because of it
i hope people don't conflate the russian
people with communism anymore just like
chinese people with communism because
the ccp's in control of that country
it's basically occupying china and the
the soviet communist dictatorship was
occupying the russian people for 100
years they're gone now and and communism
but the uniparty has a stranglehold of
the american people who
overwhelmingly reject the wars that we
have been engaging in
it's remarkable if you look at the polls
it's like do you want war it's like 87
percent no war yet we keep finding
ourselves entangled in them it's because
we
are are are subjugated by the uniparty
that will go to war no matter what you
want and they'll do it without
congressional authority like they're
supposed to get
except for donald trump
so a lot of people complain about
trump's increasing the drone strikes i
think it's bad but you take a look at
the fact that he was withdrawing our
troops that he was negotiating peace
deals in the middle east he was
negotiating peace deals in north korea
and
in exchange you basically got our troops
coming back but drone strikes increasing
in some areas and it's not it's not even
obama i still think had more drone
strikes
free every hour every day for a whole
year expansion 2015. luke casey was
explaining trump made them secretive
though we don't know how many he that's
false and he also gave control of it to
his generals so that he wasn't even
calling the shots anymore he gave him i
mean and i mean maybe i'm the like you
know count like the contrarian here in a
weird way but i'm sort of i along these
lines like do you want trump to not
crush isis in syria like no i agree with
you yeah the the issue is we want to get
our troops out we don't want to be this
expansionist military state but that
means if you look at afghanistan you
can't just snap your fingers and leave
now ron paul had a great statement he
says if you're if you're given the wrong
medication you don't stay on it you got
to get off of it i agree but you also
got to get off of it slowly depending on
what it is you can't just cut cold
turkey right and i also like think about
the the the counter factual i think you
know peter thiel made this point people
would criticize him for a palantir and
the company that you know like it's a
name yeah
it's a i mean it's a heck of an it's
like middle earth i think yeah it was
the destroying mechanism
but they would drive you insane slowly
because sauron was peering into your
soul as you used it right that's what he
named his company and so like he's
supposed to be this libertarian and
they're getting on him for setting up
this like surveillance software that
really helps the federal government
track terrorists and things like that
but teal made this argument he's like do
you think civil liberties would be
better in a world where there's another
911 or do you think they will be worse
right and so i think the the
counterfactual here is if if you don't
have sufficient drone strikes to stop
terrorism to deter and to stop attacks
here do you think and in a world where
there is an attack here what do you
think the end outcome of that will be
like if you want to keep us out of war
then the argument goes then you need
some sort of like low level
deterrence and
what's the incapacitation of certain
people and i agree only so far as the
invasion was wrong in the first place
right but to get off of that you can't
just pull the troops out like biden did
with surrendering the bagram air force
base and all that stuff my attitude is
like i don't like that we're in
afghanistan okay how do we get out let's
pull our people back and keep drones for
security and then slowly we can rescind
it when the region remains stable with
the afghan national security forces yeah
it's also the incompetence of some of
those drone strikes that kills me i
understand we need drone strikes to wipe
out some of the bad people but when they
kill the family
of course we sip this whiskey what's the
difference between a
what's it in between a uh
i might get in trouble on youtube
what's the difference between a
children's hospital
and a terror death a terrorist uh
hq
the children's hospital got hit with a
drone strike i don't know i just fly the
drone
that's from the obama era right well
yeah and
the problem is people like terrace or
whoever will will go into a hospital and
use it as a human shield
they'll be less likely to bomb me if i'm
in here and they'll be firing
anti-aircraft from the hospital and
you're like well now what choice do i
have even though we're not technically
at war it's basically the entire
israel-palestine conflict right like
that's that's that's that's the
palestinians the palestinians grand
strategy is to eventually get israel to
do you know attack their human shields
to the point that eventually the
international community just comes down
in israel like palestinians don't have
any other strategy to victory that that
is their intent that's why they use
human shield and and i think like
you know i'm not going to defend
everything israel does all the time but
when you bring that up it's like they
attack you as you're if you're some kind
of like zionists who's it's like dude
they're they're putting rocket they're
launching rockets out of schools yeah
like come on the other thing that's
crazy about the drone stuff is just how
dystopian it is to live in a place where
they're constantly in the sky
like bombing your land i worked i was a
furniture mover for like 10 years and
we'd get like prayer rugs uh from places
all over the from the middle east and we
started to see a lot of prayer rugs that
had drones stitched into the border of
whoa and it was just like a thing that
would happen a lot um so it was like
it's just crazy how it affected just the
people normal people yeah which is i
still understand why we need it but it's
also so insane that the sky is raining
bombs that's true and i think we have to
put it all in context and my thing is
like
when you start from the position of i
don't think we should have been over
there in the first place the invasions
were all really dumb and bad ron paul
had a great comment a long time ago
about mark and reprisal al qaeda did it
we do surgical strikes under market
reprisal not declarations of war against
entire countries just deposing their
governments
and uh so so we end up in that and it's
i'm a little i'm a kid it's beyond my my
power and my involvement in politics now
we want to get out and that means i
don't want you american troops on the
corners occupying cities i think that's
worse than sometimes a drone is flying
overhead and it's being used to enforce
security but i still think it's bad my
ideal is that with afghanistan trump
negotiated this withdrawal we slowly
start pulling troops out but we make
sure we're handing off security to the
afghan security forces and maintaining a
light drone presence a little bit longer
for security to back them up and
logistics and then eventually we're gone
and you got a stabilized country instead
joe biden evacuates bagram in the middle
of the night without telling the
security forces looters come in then all
of a sudden the afghan forces were
caught off guard with no plan and so
instantly the entire infrastructure is
splattered taliban rushes in wins
civilians american soldiers die
that i i can only imagine was
intentional well it's like the the air
support just evaporated right i think i
read a good article about this it was
something about how
with the moment that when biden withdrew
it wasn't the way that these like remote
outpost bases that the government was
holding the afghan government was
holding on to they were all supported by
air they didn't they didn't have like
convoys go to them they were supporting
them by helicopter they that's how they
resupplied and the moment that like the
us air support fell apart it's like well
the entire afghan army falls apart at
that point because they were completely
dependent on american contractors
providing logistics
biden told everyone like that he was
gonna pull out on that day he people
knew that that was it that was the day
they were planning on it so like the
taliban saw it coming they were ready
like that day they all rushed in because
they were like oh and that's true he
delayed it from trump's original
timeline but the idea of september 11th
yeah some stupid
symbolic
nonsense
sorry to interrupt no no no i mean
that's it i mean
uh trump trump brought the taliban in
and had to go had negotiations with them
about like what's how this is going to
go down and how we're going to leave and
what he expects of them in in in in this
move
and once he's out
they i i they knew biden i think biden
did on purpose they saw the opportunity
their assumption was probably like he's
handing it over to us now's our chance
to take it does the corporate media rag
on trump for even having talks with
taliban yeah and that happened too
because he brought he brought him aboard
camp david yeah is that where we will i
don't know about that if they went to
camp david but yeah i know the media got
on it
never how dare you negotiate with kim
jong-un and how dare you negotiate with
the taliban like we hate peace
like it's like that game of thrones line
you only make peace with your enemies
right like you know wake up it was camp
camp david yeah i don't know if it ever
actually panda i think it was going to
happen
but yeah he had planned to bring him to
washington and to camp david
i i'm all about diplomacy man diplomacy
absolutely but i don't know if that
helps rate theon's bottom line if that's
a part of the equation no probably not
like halliburtons or boeing
can we still blow up like bombs on other
planets or in safe places like
got it so they don't lose their money
let's do it let's let's all
get congress to pass a bill guaranteeing
funding for all of these companies to
fire the rockets at mars
to heat up the planet yeah right right
heat the planet up kick some dust in the
air maybe melt some ice or something yes
perfect it'll stop the war here they'll
stop incentivizing the war machine
because they're still getting be getting
paid we'll be learning how to
interplanetary bombing raids which we'll
probably use in the future that's an
earth first policy that's right right
bomb the planets that's right let's talk
about the apocalypse my friends we got
this story from new york post
billionaire peter thiel's 13.5 million
dream home in new zealand is doomed
it's been characterized as a doomsday
bunker or you know emergency hideout
there's been a bunch of billionaires
that have been talking about the end of
days and wanting to build something in
this story
actually it's i don't know if they have
pictures it's really amazing i mean this
is super cool like it's like hidden the
guys who designed the uh the olympics
in tokyo designed this wow
why are they opposing this actually like
i mean like if you're talking about it
it's like a zoning dispute isn't that
like very inherent with the
with the existing terrain like i had for
the economy but a few years ago i think
there's a cnn article out there that
says this exact area was becoming like a
doomsday prepper paradise it is right
like there's a lot of them out there
matt lauer's there yep yep millionaires
and billionaires have uh first for the
since
like the story started coming out in
like 2017 after trump gets elected
millionaires and billionaires and i'm
talking about like high-level
millionaires not like somebody's got
like 10 million but somebody's worth
like 750 they're building emergency
bunkers in new zealand they've got one
of the craziest stories i read is that
they carved out mountains with landing
strips so you can fly into the mountain
to land like in like in kingsman you
guys see kingsmen when they land in the
mountain like
so it's like the bad guy wants to kill
everybody because the planet's
overheating is basically like a bill
gates who started a tech company
and then he's like he's got a lesbian
he's like the planet is heating up and
so it's going to create a virus which is
climate change it's going to kill
everybody and so he wants to
force he wants to kill everybody to stop
that from happening
so anyway like they land their planes in
this mountain that's i've read stories
about that also you take a look at like
montanning montanning montana
wyoming
tanning spot in montana one state yeah
someone's about to incorporate right now
why amana
we need to make more states there needs
to be eastern west wyoming
right we need more republican senators
yeah we should split west virginia into
east west virginia and west west
southeast virginia
so so anyway here's i did this uh as my
my 4 pm segment but my question to you
guys is we'll expand this conversation
are millionaires are the millionaires
and the billionaires are they building
this stuff because they know something
we don't or is it because they got money
to kick around and they said why not i
think some might but there's also lots
of people with lots of money buying
places on the coast and they're also
telling us the coasts are going to flood
soon
so maybe
so maybe some do maybe some don't it's
hard to see it's like an insurer it's
like a weird type of insurance policy
you know like yeah right like i don't
think i don't know teal is necessarily
like a giant techno pessimist like he's
doing i mean he does a lot of other
things right he's funding senators and
he has a lot of different projects
but or senate races rather but it's i
mean this strikes me as the kind of
thing that's like okay it's the same
reason some of these people get dual
citizenship and like saint kitts and
nevis exactly yeah he's he's a new
zealand citizen now right so it's like
you just it's just a backup like okay
you know things could get bad right i
don't think he has that's that's that's
the question that's what i'm saying
right so you got a rich dude he's peter
thiel's worth 7.7 billion reportedly and
so you got that much money okay
it's going to cost you 13 million
dollars
out of his 7.7 billion
dude he farts that much money yeah
that's a hell yes in my book yeah so he
he's probably like i got to buy some hey
uh bill set up a company and build me
this thing in new zealand yeah i mean
that's about that
you're making you know if he's got a
billion investments are gonna make like
what eight percent a year generally so
you're thinking you're pl if you he's
just you can screw around and play with
a five percent of his net worth every
year okay well seven point seven billion
do the math five bill you know five five
percent of seven billion is what but
don't even i'm not even who even cares
about grants 50 million 7.7 billion you
don't have to work for multiple
generations like your kids are gonna
have to work yeah so i mean it's yeah i
mean this is just play money right like
that's why he's thinking about having a
meditation space in a doomsday bunker
that's a real luxury that's the last
thing i'd be thinking about in my
doomsday very very small very like
trivial insurance policy for like the
you know hedging against the collapse of
the united states or united states
becoming particularly inhospitable look
at the view is this an actual picture
from his i think it's a mock-up okay
if the view is anything like that then
it's that's better than just an
insurance policy it's a vacation home
yeah are you safe from their prime
minister though even out there in new
zealand because she's like the worst how
does that work how rich do you have to
be to be off the prime minister's radar
i don't know with her no it doesn't work
that way man
i can't remember who we had on the show
talking about
how
wealth is meaningless in apocalypse
so you think you own something
why
so like anybody who owns a house knows
this why do you own the house because
someone wrote on a piece of paper you
own the house
good luck when some some like a group of
dudes like five guys with shaved heads
and ars walk up and say get out of my
house and you go but but i have the
paper and they go that's funny i have
the gun
so when the apocalypse happens and
there's nobody to call
he can set this up that's great and then
he can be like i'm rich and i'm a
billionaire and i have this bunker and
the prime minister that crazy lady can
chop up with one guy who's got one gun
and like it's ours now and unless he's
got a way to defend himself that's an in
an apocalypse when everything breaks
down your your your deed doesn't mean
anything what you can defend is all that
matters and guess what someone as rich
as peter thiel his net worth will drop
to about
five hundred thousand dollars when an
apocalypse happens because his stocks
his his investments all that evaporate
overnight if there's a global
uh governmental crisis or collapse and
war breaks out
we we've we've not seen something this
extent like even in major wars
you'll still have international like
assets like somebody from britain can
put assets in switzerland and all that
kind of stuff it's probably why
switzerland love being neutral and
people loved that they were but if we
actually had a total global
breakdown of like international treaties
and stuff
his net worth is
is is
what he can hold in his hands that's who
who trusts him and who's gonna back him
up that's a big part of it maybe crypto
well that's why that's why you're trying
to buy a place in new zealand you think
new zealand i mean new zealand is super
remote right like the nearest place you
can fly to is australia and it's a three
or four hour flight okay it's thousands
of miles yeah and maybe he's banking in
the apocalypse the prime minister just
means nothing anyway right like so he's
just okay yeah i'll go to my i mean and
i think the odds of a universal global
apocalypse seem low right i think again
you're hedging against a united states
collapse okay right
you know yeah man saint kitts and nevis
i think it cost 50 grand to be a citizen
yeah there's there's different like
small caribbean countries that like i
think saint kitts and nevis is like the
biggest one and there and and people the
rich people love that island because
their passports are better than the
american passport because it's an island
nation of like no consequence so their
passports are basically accepted
everywhere because every country knows
you're a rich dude who's just going to
come and spend money in your country so
like whatever i don't care yeah wow
yeah so you can you can basically
i don't i've never actually researched
this but i've had friends telling me
about people who that you go there you
put you give them 50 grand and they hand
you your passport you're a citizen do
you guys have dual citizenship or
multi-citizens
where's
germany is it really when you get yeah
uh so i'm half jewish right and my
grandmother had to leave germany in uh
i don't ever forget is it 38 i think she
left really very late oh wow um and so
the german government has a program for
people who like in their view would have
been
born in germany or would have been
german descendants but for
um the nazis that they can apply for
german citizenship for a cheap for
relatively cheap like a couple grand or
something there's actually a bunch of
countries that do things like that
regardless of displacement like if you
are the grand uh son or daughter of
someone who was a citizen who like
emigrated you can apply and and right
i think i think in south korea you can
get a b visa if you're the grand son or
daughter of some of a korean citizen
yeah my wife could do that with greece
because her dad's from greece so she
hasn't but she could well i think yeah
that's her dad it's like that that's
that feels kind of like it should be
that closer yeah but even a grandparent
i kind of feel like is is an extension
right
my grandmother was a german citizen
before she fled right so you know that's
uh and i mean honestly it's not really
that valuable in the sense of i mean
well i can when i go to europe i get to
go through the short line if i have my
passport with me and yeah conceivably if
i wanted to go work in the eu
other countries though like what about
iran um
i don't know i mean might be it might be
easier for countries that have a
particularly hostile relationship with
the united states like i probably i
think german passports can get into
iran when united states passports can't
what was the story with your grandma
bailing she was full jewish in 1938 nazi
germany what she
their family had you know had plenty of
uh
i don't know exactly i actually don't
know the story of exactly how she got
out but i assume it's one of those like
she managed to cross the border or she
38. 30 i think at 38 might be 36 but i
think 38. um i can all check with my mom
um but yeah i mean it's a simple you
know that's actually you know not an
uncommon story where you know the her
family at the time had you know
businesses and you know a reasonable
amount of money and they just abandoned
it all showed up penniless in the united
states
um and uh this is just before the war
yeah was she there foreign
yeah i would think so i think that
that's
maybe that was like a hey maybe we
should get out of here right yeah she
would have been i mean she would have
been only about 20 right or 20 like she
was she was pretty young i think she was
born in like 19
19 19 maybe
um so she would have been very young but
she uh yeah or maybe even younger it was
uh it was crystal nacht was november was
9th and 10th of november 1938. okay so
maybe before that then i i don't know
but like i know that
she got out pretty late and uh it was
you know that's still you know and i
still like it's funny i mean essentially
i think most of that generation of my
family has passed at this point this is
this is the crazy thing right your your
grandmother got out before the these
violent attacks and stuff like that i
think so and i wonder you know i don't
want to compare what's happening in the
united states to uh directly to a lot of
these other countries and other
historical moments because history
doesn't repeated rhymes
but i wonder if you know looking at the
summer of love with 30 around 30 deaths
billions of dollars in damage and mass
rioting from far left ideological
extremists
i don't think is as bad as what this was
this was seriously crazy but i'm
wondering if we're getting to that point
where people are going to start being
like hey maybe we should we should move
from here and i'll put it this way i
left new york to south jersey left south
jersey to west virginia because seeing
the increasing violence
for people who are in germany germany is
a lot smaller in the united states in
the united states if you're watching
crisis happen in your cities you can go
to the country to get away from it but
i'm kind of wondering you know with the
trajectory we're on right now this is
the crazy thing right report from real
clear investigations the fbi team that
led the raid on trump's house was the
same team that led the russia collusion
investigation the hoax so this sounds
like
this sounds outright like a rogue
conspiracy or something like that and
now you know uh with this viral clip
from this show dan bungino was posting
it we had derek harvey on who mentioned
that
you know trump declassified crossfire
hurricane he probably brought copies of
the documents with him they went to get
it back because they don't want it
exposed or something like that and it
was the team that did it that went to
his house to take it this all makes
sense
they come to his house and say you
better lock this up lock it better he
does then the fbi comes back and breaks
the lock different group of fbi agents
it sounds like we're at the point where
there's different factions in the fbi
that are fighting each other
a poll just came out
that majority of the people in this
country feel
that an element of the fbi is acting as
joe biden's personal gestapo
you said that was a poll what's the poll
was it let me
we have it um
examiner says majority see fbi as
biden's personal gestapo after trump
raid this is the examiner this is not
some you know this is crazy rasmussen
survey 53 of likely voters agree there's
a group of politicized thugs the top of
the fbi that are using the fbi's joe
biden's personal gestapo
i think it's a civil war i saw them as
gestapo when they raided veritas right
like that's insane
this is this is the
the breakdown this is the culture we're
reaching the highest levels of
government that i was told would never
happen
so when you hear like like i mentioned
when you hear
that the fbi told trump's people to
secure these documents with a padlock
and they do and then a few months later
come in and smash the padlock it makes
no sense unless you point out unless the
reality is it was a different group of
fbi agents who did it
and i i had someone reach out to me
claiming to be a retired agent who said
you're exactly right there there may be
there is leadership there is leadership
at the top but different you know
managers or or you know uh supervisors
in different fields different different
interests exactly they're going to be
doing things against each other's
interests yeah i think uh well i was
actually looking into this because you
know a lot of people started talking
about defunding the fbi and i was like i
was actually thinking about what could a
president do with just an executive
order right abolish it
they could do a lot uh the fbi doesn't
have like an explicit deal much in the
way of explicit delegated authority from
congress it actually is delegated to the
attorney general who then has like the
right to appoint officials but the fbi
is sort of like implicitly
it's not actually like mandated by
congress in the same way that other law
enforcement agencies are and so
theoretically like a president and an
attorney general could essentially just
make it an executive order that's like
the fbi only does the things that is
very specifically mandated to do by
congress like track serial killers and
everything else
is that mandated by congress there's
like certain certain specific statutes
that mandate things that the fbi should
handle but they're like narrow but does
the does congress um prescribe through
statutory law the maintenance of the fbi
no
i i read or it might it might fund it
but that's that's different from saying
so that basically you'd be you you could
basically strip the fbi of authority
even if you didn't strip at a funding
vehicle
there's a meme that's going around that
that trump could sign an executive order
disbanding it outright because it's got
no congressional authority into its
existence that it was created by
executive order or something like that
yeah i think i mean
i'm not i don't know that's sure but i
just i'm i'm pretty confident though
about the ability of the president to
just kind of decide to you know say okay
guess guess what fbi like on day one
you're not doing counterintelligence
anymore right like done you don't have
you don't have any access to it i'm
allocating that authority to other
intelligence agencies oh wow it was
linked to prohibition that's where it
started huh that sounds right there's
there's a lot of i mean i think
prohibition is one of the big things
bank robberies when bank robberies were
a big deal that was like a big uh
trigger for i think it was that was like
more like when the fbi really got a lot
of its expansion because one of the one
of the problems that um there was a it
was a huge problem in the midwest where
you have all these states that are
pretty small and and like can't think
about something like kansas city where
it's across the border in kansas and
missouri so you'd have bank robbers
constantly robbing a bank in kansas and
then crossing the border in missouri and
not getting prosecuted right roosevelt
did start kind of starting an early form
of the fbi after uh
mckinley was assassinated it's
interesting how it evolved into
existence it wasn't it wasn't outright
created so when you look at the history
of the fbi it talks about the um the
national bureau of criminal
identification which eventually evolves
into the bureau of investigation which
eventually evolves into the federal
bureau of investigation it's interesting
and there was a this is interesting it
says
uh there were fears the new agency would
serve as secret police as a secret
police department again at roosevelt's
urging bonaparte moved to organize a
formal bureau of investigation which
would then have its own staff of special
agents yeah this was yeah this was teddy
roosevelt i think i'm literally just
started a book about this because i was
interested uh
teddy roosevelt was you know annoyed
with essentially you know environmental
issues actually oddly enough progressive
yeah conservative pretty progressive
like he didn't like uh you know some big
corporate interests screwing up the
environment certain states and you know
getting away with it davis national
parks yeah
this is crazy it was it was created by
the attorney general he just one day
brought in people and said reports to uh
the chief examiner chief examiner as
investigators and then they gave a name
to the group the bureau of investigation
and and then 1935 they renamed it the
federal bureau of investigation
that's it yeah in which case the
executive branch could just literally be
like you're gone yeah or or just reroute
it like basically i mean there might be
other laws or other statutes that are
like funding the fbi or essentially main
you know the civil service rules that
protect the people there okay that's all
fine but you could you could just strip
it of authority and tell them all to go
play bridge like you know not go kidnap
a governor yeah right or yeah yeah all
that you can stop doing that my animal
brain my lizard brain has a hard time
with the idea of of it erasing the fbi
because i've it's been with me my whole
life so i'm like wouldn't that cause
chaos if we don't have enough i mean you
need to replace certain of its functions
for sure right like you don't want to i
mean this is not like get rid of having
a sort of federal police force there are
things you need a federal police force
or when it comes to enforcing federal
law yes okay but i mean one thing i
joked about was you just create a new
federal justice bureau you know think
about what the acronym is fjb fjd
right agreed just for that reason we do
it right there's a new federal justice
startup petition duplicates the
functions of the fbi but you just make
all the current fbi officials like
reapply for their jobs
right that would be you know there's a
lot of like clever things you could do
given the fact that they don't
the whole the institution doesn't have
that much statutory protection how
amazing would it be if donald trump gets
reelected and then immediately following
his inauguration and swearing in he
doesn't address where he's like my
fellow americans you may remember a few
years ago when the fbi
came into my home
it was terrible terrible everyone says
it was one of the most terrible things i
am signing a negative order there is no
more fbi i just it would be hilarious
not a good move
he's not going to care he's like do
something i don't know i understand the
need for it though i do i get it but
this has got to go this is oh yeah
it needs to be like radical oh my
goodness like it's just a corrupt right
now the institution itself is really
corrupt what president started the cia
um but which everyone did
after jfk was assassinated i believe
that president wrote a letter like an
op-ed saying we got to disband the cia
because he was convinced
he was convinced like they had something
to do with it harry truman 1944 it was
true
yeah truman said he created it after jfk
was assassinated then he wrote a letter
saying we got to disband the cia and
then the head of the cia went and
visited truman and said you got to not
say that and he was like nah i'm sorry
hold on so like truman created it yep
and then after jfk died he wrote a
letter saying an op-ed or something
saying like i think they got too much
power wow that's not what i intended
yeah crazy interesting i don't know
about like i think the cia certainly
does have you know its fingers and some
bad stuff like a lot of bad stuff
actually but domestically it's like
sounds like it's mostly the fbi yeah
yeah well the other thing other unique
thing you could do is you know we
are kind of unique among western
countries and that we have both the same
institution handles both like federal
policing and counterintelligence and
those are not norm those are not
necessarily like combined functions
right one is like detecting spies and
like thwarting foreign intelligence
efforts and the other is like just
federal police work right
you know investigating crimes and
helping the doj prosecutors if if donald
trump is going to get rid of the the fbi
i just he's got to preserve the x-files
and make sure that they're the one thing
is the x-files real though like it's an
action it was an actual like the actual
show was based off of like the filing
they would do for things they couldn't
explain not like any agents actually
like aliens are among us but they're
like hey we don't know how this happened
this is crazy
if if people out there have watched the
latest episode of tales from the
inverted world they would have seen the
letter i wrote to president carter
me demanding transparency of uh he you
know when he was on the campaign trail
he promised to release all ufo documents
because carter saw ufo in georgia
and then he talked about it extensively
on the campaign trail promising this and
the second he got into office like most
politicians do he backpedaled and didn't
release anything because of national
security quote unquote
um but i'm still trying to hit him up oh
yeah
yeah i think they were drone programs a
lot of what people were told were alien
or just
whether or not they have fusion packs on
board i wonder and that's what i tell
them actually it could be
extraterrestrials it could be our
military it could be it is it is totally
fictional but i i remember reading just
want to clarify that i remember reading
something that it was like the idea of
the show came from something that was
really within the fbi yeah air force was
the air force yeah i just said well i
just saw an article was there a real
life version of the x-files the answer
is yes and it was part of the air force
uh alex hollings let me see if i can
find the exact
who says it's false yes
wikipedia oh that's no it says it's fbi
yeah but that's that's the thing like it
says a fictional uh case deemed
unsolvable by the fbi i read somewhere
that the show was inspired by
something that like it's not literally
the x-files but like somebody was
reading about how the fbi couldn't solve
something and they're like oh we should
do a show like that and call it
something well they have certainly done
experiments like the remote viewing
stuff where they'd sit the cops in a
room or just bring people i believe it
was fbi well you know about the men who
stare at goats i haven't seen it but
yeah i know about it well like that what
is based on right right yeah the
stargate giving them uh were they
drugging them up
yeah what's the ghost so weird do they
actually stare at goats
weren't they trying to explode them or
something oh i don't know about that i
think they were trying to use
telekinesis to kill goats i'm not sure
i read i read about this
but yeah the u.s people like yo bro we
were talking about some crazy stuff
downstairs like cia masks
like this super high-tech mission
impossible kind of masks that they have
the the heart attack gun yep bro the
heart attack gun is real oh yeah oh it's
hilarious you can go and there was a
great channel on youtube i think they
nuked it it was called film archives and
this person would upload great
congressional hearings from the 50s 60s
70s 80s up until now actually and uh
there was one with the heart attack gun
there kind of just passing around the
heart attack gun you're like oh so so
you shoot this at someone and give them
a heart attack okay the cia's heart
attack gun yeah no doubt no doubt so
they had that in the 60s or 70s what
frozen shellfish toxin would enter the
target's bloodstream and kill them in
mere minutes but i kind of wonder like
couldn't you just put
like uh
oh my god anything real yeah
that's yeah that's it that's it so the
idea was back then i guess it was hard
to detect the toxin so if you if someone
was shot by the dart they would die and
they'd be like i don't know what
happened these days
i mean there's so much stuff
i was reading about
certain like vitamin mixtures that can
cause cardiac arrest heart attacks and
that when they did your blood test
they would just see like potassium and
sodium and stuff and be like i don't
know but like we've way advanced the
craziness of this i will say though
if a a powerful intelligence agency
wants to kill somebody it's really easy
you get mugged yeah yeah that's it yeah
it's an easy way of covering it up so
you're walking down the street
outlandish measures right exactly
that's just diabolical havana effect
tamanna syndrome oh the the sound that
they're doing yeah i wonder if they're
microwave blasting people yeah
yeah well that means it's not sound but
it was affecting them uh it was sonar or
something they're blasting into them
well we don't know if it's sonar yeah
what we know is that people reporting
hearing like a buzzing noise right or a
humming noise right and then they would
get photosensitivity they'd become like
amnesiac like their memories would
become you know screwed up and they'd
it's that's nightmarish dude
if you start hearing a weird buzzing
like
don't just be like that's not that you
should just leave the room i guess or
what i don't know
look up there's no escape
yeah
if i used to think about this i think
i've talked about this on the show so
i'd have this face like what if all of a
sudden everyone on earth wanted to kill
me like how long could i survive
in this room probably about seven
seconds because there's four you guys
if i'm driving i don't know i would take
this christmas
like the swords yeah there's the katana
yeah the civil war era musket anywhere
you are on earth
that feels like an episode of fortnite
if you're actually this is an episode
like an escape room but but we're trying
to try and drive kind of
like well what is the best weapon
inside the deep state probably the gun
so we're talking about like that just
gonna load it though i take a guitar i
think their their purpose is to maintain
stability the media ultimately that's
pretty good and if they think that
you're a threat to stability then
they'll start to take an eye on you but
if they think that you're helping them
provide stability to the what the people
of earth is that the plan dude they will
get you no matter what even if you're
innocent bystander i just think of when
hillary clinton apologized to everyone
for back in the day when we dose people
in guatemala with syphilis you know just
random people you know we'll we'll just
get you just because we want to know how
what happens when syphilis goes through
the human body without being treated or
well same thing we did to tuskegee
what's this what's this guatemala
syphilis thing
it's like an extension of the tuskegee
syphilis experiment i pulled up the
sonic weapon wikipedia and they
mentioned havana syndrome uh it caused
hearing loss and other problems they
thought it was sonic attacks but now
more recent reports hypothesize
microwave energy as the cause well
there's also like a whole bunch of stuff
about this being fake right having a
syndrome like was like it was a mental
thing yeah it was like a scenario but
but i think there's something the latest
stuff that i read is there's way too
many reports of it that it's it's like
with the same symptoms right that it and
and it's like isolated to location so
it's there's something there i think i
equate it to the sound because they at
the a few years ago they were using
those um to get rid of riots they blast
device okay so i'm i'm in i think i'm in
anaheim
three blocks down the road i can see a
line of police
all of a sudden i hear as if someone was
standing right next to me you must
disperse this is an illegal protest or
an illegal demonstration and then i was
like i turned them like
what though and people are like look and
you can see the the lrad on top of the
vehicle they also do this high pitch
thing at you and it like it hurts but
it's not if they wanted to they could
make your ears bleed
crazy stuff but i'll tell you some of
the craziest stuff i've ever read i
don't know how true this is that ultra
low frequencies are one of the reasons
they think people report haunted houses
so that when you get hit by ultra low
frequencies you can't interpret it as
sound but it hits your body in waves
which causes like a sensation of someone
being around you it causes like feelings
of dread heart rate increasing so people
maybe when they think they're seeing a
ghost they could be it could be hit by
ultra low frequencies of energy rushing
through them yeah crazy stuff like that
yeah interesting oh yeah i'm beginning
to think that like ghosts as much as i
love the idea is a me thing and not a
ghost thing it's like my interpretation
it's probably both i couldn't think that
the human spirit is real and like we
have these magnetic fields but also that
we're bomb the humans are experimenting
by bombarding ourselves with radiation
and
you know low frequencies like harp
h-a-r-p i don't know if you guys studied
much of it oh yeah high altitude i
talked to some people at harp for uh
volume one of inverted world and they're
like firing i thought they were killing
the birds
might be happening by on accident i
think they are uh it's all it's weird to
think that ghosts are real and that
we're interacting with ghosts yeah i
think i want to clarify i do think there
are ghosts also because i grew up with
one very nonchalant good ghost blue
collar ghost but also i think a lot of
people
yeah what's wrong with white collar
ghosts
i hate white collar ghosts why i mean
why do you have terrible
when you have a blue-collar ghost like
what happens is like you wake up in the
middle of night with your plumbing fixed
yeah you get a white-collar ghost like
they're just sitting there complaining
about taxes and yeah what's going on
they could do your taxes for you why are
you so discriminatory guys no i just
didn't know him i just didn't provide
you legal services
i was in the middle of the woods because
there wasn't a lot of white coffee a
hilarious bit like a guy wakes up and he
sees a ghost and he's like what are you
doing and it's like your taxes
[Music]
oh and he had a white collar ghost in in
uh okay bro i know what you're doing
yeah you want to know what ghosts are of
course let's do this so
uh do you know about m theory membrane
theory i know that the universe is a
multi-dimensional folding fabric that
moves through and it's all crazy like
okay i only half know what i'm talking
about so i probably mish-mashed crazy
physics ideas to create some weird
theory about ghosts that's science yeah
think about this way if time is not
linear
but uh if you expand out of like our
perception of time being linear but if
you then zoom out above it and it's more
of like this this you know moving fabric
what if time is a cube
perhaps but but but imagine it this way
what's your shelf because i was reading
like remember
so you've got uh 1827
all right and there is some dude wearing
18 20 27 clothes
and then somebody in 2016
walks into a building that was a
historic building that was built in
1827. so the framing is all relatively
similar the floors are in the same
places where the floors were all that
stuff this person in 2016 walks into a
room and then all of a sudden sees a
semi-transparent figure standing before
him wearing clothes from the 1820s and
for a brief moment looks at them and
goes
and they go what the word they run away
screaming i just saw a ghost you know
really happened
the fabric of time between that hundred
or almost 200 year gap brushed against
each other and very briefly
that man
in the 1820s clothes who saw the figure
from the future screamed
seeing a ghost they both thought each
other with ghosts then that guy writes
down this house is demonic it is haunted
that story gets passed down and people
are like whoa a haunted house then the
person in the future goes there and when
the time intersects briefly just for a
flicker of a moment they both see each
other and create right the paradox two
separate existences in two separate
times folding into one another very
briefly though briefly right and so so
this is why old buildings tend to be
haunted
and uh
it so like if if the building was
knocked down and a different building
was built the floors would be in
different places so the guy who's
standing on the second floor would not
appear to the same guy in the second
floor because they're in they've moved
right but if the building is the same
building from the 1800s but remodeled
and and just reinforced over time
you would quite literally be standing in
front of the person
in the same physical space as time
brushed past itself this is like the
ghost i grew up with because i grew up
in a house that was built in the 1700s
a lot of people died around that time as
well in that house but the ghost that i
investigated for inverted world last
year um
he was i shared his room you know i
think and i think we just crossed paths
because we were in like the same room
the same kitchen and he
i i think was just like he felt comfort
living there with us because uh he lost
his family and now he here he was with
us time cube what is this i don't know
who brought this i don't really
know this is like i i didn't completely
make this up uh because i remember when
i did college debate people would argue
this is like a response to anything on
the affirmative when they had no idea
whether they instead you know they would
get up and argue for some policy change
and they'd be like in the negative we'll
get up and be like time is a cube
we can see
this is a guy who said that all modern
science sciences are participating in a
worldwide conspiracy to teach lies
by omitting his theories alleged truth
that each day actually consists of four
days occurring simultaneously
i like it what is that what does that
even mean
i don't think anyone knows time is a
cute when people people will give you
their theories you got to keep in mind
that just because one theory is right
doesn't mean another theory isn't also
right because like i think a lot of
these different scientific theories
they're arguing about which one's the
right one a lot of them are just
explaining the system from different
perspectives so a lot of them are
correct like string theory is probably
real um nassem harriman's source child
proton papers
are part real as well yeah but they're
different levels different distances
from the truth so they look different
coming into it i think science is is all
wrong and it always has been oh
and what i mean by that is
we think we know so much and we
constantly prove ourselves wrong
so there's probably there's obviously a
ton of stuff we clearly know like we've
been able to make glass bottles mass
produce dvds build computers we clearly
understand very you know powerful
scientific
powerful science but when it comes to
the abstract and theoretical stuff we
probably are getting
almost all of it wrong well i mean i
don't know i i would say science is the
whole art of knowing essentially all
science does is disprove things yeah the
scientific method right that this is
basic like pot karl popper and like what
is a scientific statement all i mean the
idea is that science doesn't actually
say anything is true well so the the you
guys want to know the secret to reality
is that we shape it through our
observation i learned that from watching
a documentary called the secret yeah
people know this um and the way it
really works is you decide what's true
and then find evidence to back it up and
then assert it as truth and that's how
you successfully become a leftist yeah
you can see the future that's how you
collapse the city
if a baseball is flying towards you the
light reflecting off the baseball hits
your eye before the baseball gets there
so you see it before it is there you
have to start to anticipate access
possibilities
process the information
fast enough
well we
we perceive it as anticipation so you
know where it's going to be but you're
actually seeing it before it gets there
and it's like .08 seconds you know you
can see into the future 0.08 seconds so
i think when people have like if we ever
go to talk to someone and you have like
you get afraid right before you say it
then they react to the fear or if you're
like brave right before you say it they
react to the bravery that's how ozzie
mendius caught the bullet when silk
specter 2 fired at him in his antarctic
laboratory he saw the light faster he
hit it and caught in his hand and that's
how he survived i think you're right
about ghosts being trapped to locations
because there's this phantom dna
experiment where they'll put dna inside
of a vacuum bombard it with photons and
the photons start to spin around the dna
as if it's there with it then they
remove the dna from the vacuum the
photons stay there as if the dna was
still there for like two weeks the
photons will stay there and rotate and i
wonder if that's just like an example of
how long a ghost or a piece of energy
could be bound to a spot and like i
think time is a cube bone
i think that bones in a graveyard are
like an anchor for energy like that like
ghost energy i i think you know the
reality is that uh there's a conspiracy
to uh use fluoride to calcify our third
eye
because
humans do have the ability to shape
reality but the global elites don't want
the
peasants to be able to yeah don't get me
started on our third world war it really
is friday night
[Laughter]
this is a real conspiracy theory that um
so the double slit experiment we've
talked about before and then there's
another one someone brought up that was
even crazier but you guys are familiar
with the double slit experiment right no
it's uh
i'll try to simplify it
they they take like a metal sheet they
put a slit in it they fired electrons
and they got a particle pattern like
okay then they did two slits and they
fired electrons and they got a wave
pattern
and so they're like okay uh that's weird
why are we getting a wave pattern it
should be a particle pattern let's
measure which slit each electron is
going through when they did they got a
particle pattern again
so what the hippie said was whoa
like by looking at it like all of a
sudden it changed
and what physicists said was our
measurement procedure interfered with
the process and we don't know why which
is the smarter reasoning but so so these
people believe that human observation
has the ability to shape reality so
you'll you'll hear new age people talk
about manifesting things like my friend
robbie who was like so they're trans
they're tr they're what manifest
human observation has the power to shape
reality sure but no but they can't they
mean it more literally than that so i'm
trying to park my car and i'll at my
friend robbie's house shout out robbie
yeah robbie what's going on dude and he
i was like yo rob he was like where are
you at i'm like trying to find a parking
space he goes oh bro manifested yeah
what are you waiting and i was like what
and he's like bro manifest a parking
spot
i was like dude i can't manifest a
parking spot not that attitude
[Laughter]
so people believe that if you will it
will happen
and that the reason why we've lost that
ability is because the global elites are
putting florid in the water
so that it would calcify our pineal
glands which are our third eye that
grant us the ability
it's a it's a beautifully absurd idea i
experimented with
fun right right from like 2006-7 i made
youtube videos about manifestation i was
one of these hippie freaks tim's talking
about
i'm going to manifest a glass of water
and i'd be sitting there thinking like
water is in front of me i'll fix that
later water is in front of me there's
water and i just like visualize and
relax and like empty my mind what would
happen is someone would come in and
they'd be like hey you want a glass of
water and i'd be
go yeah and i realized i'm not making
things apparate out of nowhere i'm
affecting the human consciousness with
my thoughts
or sometimes people sometimes
coincidence you could call but i don't
think there are coincidences in reality
you know i i do have to be honest though
i've i've slowly stopped believing in
some coincidences just because the
reality that we're in has become so
absurd it doesn't feel like probability
makes sense it's post reality no just
just like everything that's happened
with uh
trump and the way he behaves and the
things that are happening it's like
how is this probabilistic it should be
so exceedingly but so many strange
things are happening at once that it
seems like we've won the lottery 10
times in a few years like brian stelter
and liz cheney going out in the same
week is like come on that's like winning
the lottery twice in two days
but but it really is you know like and
then people are saying it comes in
threes now why is that it comes in
threes we used to say that about deaths
at the hospital and people are saying
that sam harris was the third
sam harris canceled himself with this
insane statement and it's like that
that's actually a good point liz cheney
loses brian gets fired and sam harris
implodes on a show into insane virality
and then i'm thinking of all the
technology we have right now this is
like winning the lottery having access
to electricity and tv and video oh yeah
yeah so like that's not a coincidence
this is not a coincidence that these
things are happening this is intentional
we're creating i just wonder if
sometimes the world is the world i think
is always absurd humans are always
absurd and beautiful and maybe now we're
seeing all the coincidences because of
all the information that we have access
to you know maybe the weird things were
always happening i mean there is
obviously like serious observation bias
and yeah like
things kind of i mean yeah but that said
yeah you're right we live in an awesome
play world we're so lucky to have what
we have and it's also creating creating
things that we wouldn't have ever
anticipated yeah i'll let you guys in on
a secret though uh that documentary the
secret have you ever seen it
no i've heard about it but you gotta
watch it
it's from like the early 2000s or
something like 2007 2007 late 2000's and
the secret is that all like powerful
people throughout history believed in
the concept of like manifestation is
that what it is more or less yeah if you
it's like like attracts like kind of
idea so i will tell you this
although like the very successful and
well-off people i know the majority of
them really do believe they have magic
powers and you think i'm exaggerating
like bro i've sat down with famous
actors and actresses and celebrities and
they casually talk about their magic
and then you look at these people
and their wealth and success and i'm
like my view is perhaps because you've
had an easy life of wealth and success
you assume you must have magic and it's
actually malignant narcissism
but these people actually believe
no the reality is that they believe in
their magic and that's granted them easy
access and easy life
and you know what i can accept about
some of that is like yeah it really
doesn't make sense how you got to this
position it's not like you worked really
hard and earned it it's like you went to
the right place at the right time and
then got chosen and all sudden you're
successful and rich it's like well the
reality is you're a driven person who
sought out opportunity and you had the
talent and drive and
passing that off as magic is just you're
kind of insulting yourself
i mean it's also a fake humility
right like you're saying right right
you're saying you didn't actually you
know oh i just you know i just i just
got lucky i just happen to have these
powers but but they're not saying
they're lucky they're saying they will
it into existence like that they choose
what happens and it happens for them
they choose to make money and then they
get money and things like that it's like
they have force powers i wonder if they
think we all have access to that power
and they're just using it better well
that's something a lot of them just say
stuff like that like the calcification
of the paneling like the loss of access
to the dmt sometimes people will say
gives you less access to your magic yeah
i think it's simple i think that idea of
like a vision board they say like put
your goals on a board in your room and
then every day you look at it and i'm
like you know the saying out of sight
out of mind well there's an inverse of
that if you're focused on it every day
it's not magic it's just you're
directing yourself
and yeah you're staying focused it's
that simple well here's a weird i'll try
to tell a story quickly but it was
christmas eve many years ago i was going
down to times square to see my wife and
um i was on the train reading a book an
old lady sat next to me she wanted to
see what book i was reading she was
interested in it was a saul bello book
and
i had no idea who she was
i had just graduated from my writing
program
i had no life no money nothing she's
talking to me it was great we
we leave she says goodbye and she
whispers in my ear i'm kurt vonnegut's
widow
and i love kurt vonnegut and the only
thing on my wall at the time was a quote
from kurt vonnegut i had that taped on
my wall for a year
and i just graduated the writing program
with that looking at that every day and
i just so happened to be on the train
something i never did really all that
much because i was upstate to see my
family i was like what are the odds that
i just graduated this program thinking
of vonnegut this whole time and then his
ex-wife
is sitting next to me i've had so much
stuff in my life
that's just been like that it's bizarre
that it makes you i think for a lot of
people if you haven't experienced that
then you're less likely to be faithful
or religious in some capacity yeah but
for people this is the funny thing like
i talk to people who are like really not
religious and they never have stories
like that i ask them about it and then
you meet someone who's religious they'll
tell you about serendipity or like these
these these magical moments in their
lives that they feel is like outside of
probability and so it makes them believe
that we were we were experiencing
something greater something more
constructed yeah whatever it was maybe
it was magic maybe it was just
coincidence but it i i cried and when
she left i was like holy crap and i used
that as like a symbol for me to be like
i'm on some kind of right path i think
people are
are like
i guess you call them uh pattern
recognition machines and when you're
thinking something your brain activity
is creating a neural pattern yeah
whether or not
you might not perceive it but her brain
is perceiving it whether or not you can
see it yeah i don't think and then i got
to go to her house i saw where ivana
wrote like i became friends with her you
know i'm still talking to her and like i
got to see his desk i got to see all
this stuff so it was like it blew my
mind we got to go to super chats we're a
little behind if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe subscribe to this channel head
over to timcast.com become a member so
uh if you want to check out all the
shows we're launching of course you want
to check out tales from the inverted
world season two and we got a bunch of
stuff happening in that area because
obviously we love talking about pop
culture check out pop culture crisis we
love talking about weird and wild like
tales from the inverted world and the
news we hit all three of those points
today which is great because yeah
kardashians cia more of this right
here we go tiberius says god we are
living in the future ian have you seen
the nuclear diamond batteries or the
handheld coil gun god are we in the
future it's amazing uh i haven't seen
the handheld coil gun but hell yes i've
seen the nuclear batteries the nuclear
diamond batteries yeah uh i think that
there's a bit of leftover nuclear waste
that they put inside of diamond and then
it produces um oh gosh how does it
produce charge is it a neutron pulse
that it's sending out sending out some
sort of pulse through the diamond that's
and then the diamond is vibrating and
then capturing the energy i believe
creates a really low power electrical
charge for like 10 000 years never and
it's nuclear waste that you use to make
the batteries oh i've heard of that i
think we talked about it before yeah we
could it's a couple years ago it was a
breakthrough all right augusto mimoshay
says shane a good friend of mine and i
want to do an on-site investigation into
the mythical dolce new mexico alien base
you win
that sounds like fun yeah what isn't
dangerous i don't know anything about it
but i'm in it's it's it's it's really
cool
people have submitted weird like ghost
stories to shane and now you've like
you're lining up these investigations
yes it's
i love the ghost hunter stuff but i
don't like how fake it is i want a real
ghost on yeah that's what i say like
when i was in this in this town for uh
volume 2 of inverted world it's kind of
known for ghosts so they know a lot of
the ghost hunter types and they show up
with like the whatever the machines and
that's not what i do at all i like the
stories and hearing the experiences but
i'm not going to try to prove something
because i think it's ridiculous
there are machines that can find really
low like sensitivity but you need to
somehow dampen the outer layer around
you like with a faraday mechanism to not
have interference all right tim i need a
faraday mechanism yeah i think i got
jerry yes i think the alien scientist
can build one
yeah i'm gonna hit up elon all right
all right
omega rasetsu says tim is wrong it's all
about looks for both men and women dude
gets friend zoned because he is not
attractive to women 80 goes for top
twenty percent of men that's that that's
totally not true well that's true of uh
that's true of dating apps sure when
it's when it's superficial but this
story i'm talking about this guy
bro i know
short little weasley dudes who got all
the ladies because they're
powerful men because they figured out
how to um succeed how to dominate
conversations
confidence yeah all of that stuff very
like you know traditionally like like
aesthetically attractive man will become
extraordinarily unattractive to a woman
if he behaves like a coward well so
there's a i think this was the science
of sex this this thing they didn't hp a
long time ago they they had women rate a
bunch of men on a scale of of uh one to
ten
and then they took the pictures
and they showed them to women on the
street and said how would you rate this
man and sure enough
the average score the man got was around
the same score the woman on the street
would give him so this guy in like a
flannel shirt with like chiseled and a
beard and he looks tall they're like oh
he's a nine he's a nine they then
took these things and added biographical
information
and that same guy who was a nine they
wrote that he was a theater manager who
made thirty five thousand dollars a year
and the woman rated him a seven
they took the guy who was rated a four
and they said he was a computer software
engineer who made six hundred thousand a
year and they rated him a seven
so like that stuff matters to women for
obvious reasons yeah they want genetic
superiority for their children and if
they think that you can get them money
and safety with your personality you're
going to be much more attractive it's
success it's like this is safe and
important that the success of the man's
status is
for guys it's like
do can she reproduce
yeah no i mean it's like the idea that
it's just looks for men is i mean
completely completely false it's not
true at all it's bi-modal for guys it's
not all looks but it's mostly looks and
for women it's it's it's not
mostly looks but looks do matter yeah it
looks mad i mean looks matter like it's
like looks to get you in this definitely
matter but it's also like can we have a
family like healthy right can we raise
kids in this really absurd world like
are you competent are you socially are
you basically competent like if you're a
complete slob then you're not yeah so
i was such a loser nerd in high school
and as soon as i got to college i
started acting and as soon as i got a
good roll and like did a good job on
stage i got the hottest girlfriend i
gotta i gotta give a slow clap to
courtesy on this one
he super chats if uncle ben had a gun as
per the second amendment he probably
would be alive but they lived in new
york and ben probably couldn't carry a
gun legally and now peter lives with
guilt
friday night truth
that is that hit the nail on the head
that actually is
correct
i would love to see
spider-man be like i fail to see where
that's my problem and then you walk
outside and hear a gunshot and he goes
uncle ben and uncle ben's like i got him
son we're good
the criminal the armed criminal pulls
out a gun to try and steal his car and
ben just was like nope it's like it's my
right to defend myself and then
spider-man's like wow and then but then
ben says the same thing son with great
power comes great responsibility that'd
be awesome if i had let that man go who
was armed and trying to kill people who
knows he could have killed somebody's
uncle right and then spider-man just
becomes a second amendment advocate
bruce wayne's parents could have done it
too that's his heroes
you know what we need to do we need to
do skits of like superhero origin
stories but their parents had guns
because like how many how many origin
stories like the kid got orphaned
it's like oh it's like a disney movie oh
uncle ben pulls a gun john
what was uh bruce wayne's dad's name tom
tom with thomas
i'm gonna say john wayne thomas wayne i
think he's like
it's a scene where the guy's like give
me your money be cool i'm grabbing my
wallet bang
superman and he goes and that son is why
you carry it right and then the end of
the story is bruce wayne just becomes a
normal big law litigator
right like just a normal normal rich kid
turned big wild litigator
i need to like commission somebody like
you like make these shorts
just as a lawyer
yeah actually we could took we could
look at tons of origin stories and just
like correct them with like same
policies so they don't happen right yeah
like the whole traumatic event doesn't
happen and then they ended up living
some normal boring life like
the joker the joker story is actually
like really simple too he gets like he
gets good health care from a good doctor
with like a proper health system and
then you know he's just lives a normal
life right has like three kids becomes a
comic
[Laughter]
what other what other tragic origin
stories well superman that dad would get
like a bazooka and blow up the asteroid
i don't know maybe they could use some
giant weapon space weapon that they've
been building to blow up the asteroid
and save the planet the uh
superintendent was destroyed because is
it an asteroid well depending on which
iteration of it it was that they were
like over developing and had destroyed
the planet's core or something like that
so that could be like
environmentalism i guess but it's not as
funny as thomas wayne
yeah the real uncle ben being armed that
was great dude
uncle ben just shooting the guy before
he shoots him
he's like remember son this is why we
carry spider-man then instead of making
web shooters he just brings guns with
him
yeah it's a western now yeah yes i'm
into that perfect
all right
fabian alvarez says tim did you guys see
the huge drug bust in florida drugs
flying from lax and bags unhidden in
domestic flights to florida what
well i'm confident rhonda sanders is
going to clean up those streets man we
need to go full singapore i'm getting
more and more like hardcore i used to be
like so anti-war on drugs and i'm going
to the opposite position which is like
not singapore i'm not i'm not you know
not weed singapore kills yeah
i mean one of the points they made it i
i had never actually heard this
articulated very well like think about
like a fentanyl dealer and like how many
deaths they cause as a result of their
dealing like way more than a single
murder yeah are they is that a violent
act because if you sell someone a drug
that kills them are you then killing
them i mean i kind of think you are yeah
i mean i think you're you're morally
culpable right like you're selling
someone an addictive substance that will
like eventually that eventually kills
some very large percentage of them right
like i would say that you're morally
culpable right yeah with fentanyl for
sure you know and so you know that's
that's the position of singapore they're
like and unless we have are this
draconian otherwise and we have mass
drug use it's just do they draw the line
in certain drugs are they like
different
basically it's like it's the death
penalty for certain
trafficking amounts right like above a
certain amount it's a trafficking amount
that's the death penalty what's the
amount you know depends on the drug
right oh yeah that was probably very
small right for heroin it's like
extremely small right like they're just
and they just have you know i mean i
think it makes more moral sense from
that i guess from singapore's
perspective they're a small country and
they just have warnings like when you
come into singapore they're like we have
the death penalty for drug trafficking
don't even think about it
right yeah selena kyle uh that's
catwoman isn't it yeah says speaking of
kardashians just amassing wealth and not
doing enough what's enough kim is
working on getting men out of prison
willing to meet up with trump to
advocate for her cause and went to law
school is that enough yes i totally
agree yeah poorly yeah i wasn't saying
i i should clarify in case it came off
in case i did say that i'm not saying
she wasn't i'm talking about there are a
lot of people who just to mass wealth
and don't do anything but that is
respectable she works on criminal
justice reform ride share programs i
think people are getting out of jail she
was hooking up a program for them to get
car rides to job interviews you know
also awesome yeah but but i will stress
too like
maybe it's better that some people don't
do anything because otherwise you get
like a mackenzie bezos who puts two
billion dollars into websites yeah some
people should just take their money and
you know spend it on rich people things
like that their judgement
is a good cause is just not good enough
yeah
let's see what we got
kc 91 says hey guys from australia love
all your work and listen every day while
i'm working keep it up ian you always
make me look at things from a different
angle even if i don't agree that's it
perfect you won but the danger is always
doing it you've got to find balance
sometimes you want to look at it
straight ahead yeah it's easy to dance
off that cliff of sanity sometimes yeah
being too old to find it in your brain
gem r says in the internet age we're
going to have to have to be more
accepting we're going to have to be more
accepting of politicians being real
whether that's a 36 year old partying or
someone having crap opinions on twitter
at 16
that you know i get that though but
when that that finnish prime minister
was like booty dancing and stuff
apparently like the guy kissing her and
the dance isn't her husband yeah like
there's a lot going on there and the
other thing is
we we do have to expect people to be
more real
but um you'll never see a video of me
doing that well never say never everyone
just said oh shucks i mean like
i do sweaty come on i do goofy stuff and
we'll probably film stuff with uh with
cass castle but my point is that
when you're looking for a leader there
are people right now
who are
might might goof off a little bit in
that way but world leaders tend to be
very steadfast and serious or at least
that's what we expect i was talking
about this in a segment earlier
everyone's partying in the city with the
city lights going off and the soldiers
at the city walls are standing steadfast
to make sure everyone's safe and that's
the person you want leading your country
to make sure you're safe as you're
dancing not to have the leader go off
and go dancing when when russia's
knocking on your door with nuclear
weapons yeah you're military commanders
should not be getting drunk with the
troops yeah i i i actually think about
that like think about if you're just a
random soldier in the finnish military
what you'd think of seeing you're the
leader of the head of the government
acting this way yeah like especially
with like you know you just joined nato
russia's threatening a nuclear
deployment on your border like there's a
lack of seriousness there that i would
be annoyed by like is she the head of if
i were serving is she the head of their
military
i don't i don't know if they have the
same sort of commander-in-chief
structure but i assume i mean she has
she's the head of government i assume
the government would declare war like if
they ever went to war
the government is responsible for
setting the rules of the draft and the
rules of their service
roberto lara says so what tim is saying
is the billionaires are building
doomsday bunkers and becoming dual
citizens to dare i say evading the tax
the rich phrase
uh bro it is crazy how the rich get away
with not paying taxes yeah they don't
they don't need to go to new zealand and
set up a thing to not pay taxes they
just don't pay taxes but but it's it's
like
there's i really do feel like there's no
real way to solve the issue of like
getting people who have massive amounts
of wealth to pay taxes and i'm not
talking about wealth tax garbage that
makes no sense there's there's an issue
of just how when you have a ton of money
how you can structure it to where you
don't pay money on the income generated
bit capital gains or otherwise
like the panama papers for instance like
we know it
i'm not offended taxes though so i'm not
entirely sure like if the solution is
just give the money to the government
i'm not opposed to a taxation system if
the government wasn't overtly corrupt so
you know i'm not gonna pretend to have
the answers i'm just gonna sit on the
fence how about that
be cool if the government was like
here's what we need and then we paid for
that with the taxes as opposed to them
being like this is how much money we
need then they don't tell you what it's
for yeah
where's it going justify it yeah
it's like all the taxes i was paying in
new york i don't know where they went
the infrastructure was terrible crazy
taxes too terrible crazy savior says lex
friedman had an intriguing conversation
with donald hoffman about the nature of
reality consciousness and the future of
science and physics truly mind-bending
stuff that's what we got to get going
with the inverted world podcast yeah
originally it was just a podcast yeah or
it was actually like arnold's articles
in a podcast but now that we've like
kind of changed it we are like we need a
more podcast element of conversations
about this stuff instead of the
storytelling stuff
we did do a great series of members only
interviews and ian was my first guest
and it was amazing we should do that
again yeah that's really good well once
once tim locks me in the haunted house
again uh you're afraid to go get locked
in whenever you want bro
i'll we're gonna do it soon so you'll be
back and yeah donald hoffman's pretty
cool he's got some pretty freaky ideas
about reality and observation
one cool thing too is that um the pr we
have the music video for our song only
ever wanted which is like 90 done
the ad for it is up in times square
shane is the star along with his wife
nancy is the and she's the the star of
the song art itself that's wild so he we
locked him in a haunted house and then
filmed him fighting with his wife you
know yeah he's like he made me fight my
wife
it's like the joker scene he broke a
pool stick
i told my henchman
they make her cry yeah you'll see you'll
see
the video looks awesome though and the
song is real is really cool
yeah yeah totally worth it we're still
fighting now it's um
we couldn't even figure out the genre
it's like a weird pop and also rock but
it's like two different songs almost
it's like same song but
we've had a tremendous response for it
so i'm excited we'll see what happens
it's like um
it's like very emotional yeah kind of
pop song i guess i don't know i hate
even using genres i hate thinking of it
i know it's like the easy route but but
for me that song is just catchy it's
been stuck in my head a lot so that's
how it's a good thing we should show
we'll wait once it launches we'll show
it on the show yeah because uh
the way we we we want to have an impact
on the culture so we were hoping that it
charts and does all that normal stuff
like you know john rich's progress hit
number one on itunes for like eight days
or whatever he was billboard i think
billboard top 65 which is huge in the
hot 100 i think it was high 165 that's
massive yeah that's great so you know
we're hoping that we can start building
culture and then
you know what i see with the daily wire
when they do this stuff they just hired
a disney executive
and a lot of people were like you better
explain why you're doing this and i'm
like bro this is amazing they work for
them now
like the executives of disney are going
to work for conservative guys like
that's called winning yeah like you are
you are absorbing all of that i think
it's fantastic it's like pro operation
paperclip when the yeah
the nazi scientists
well
it did benefit the us
yeah yeah use those rockets to get to
the moon if it's even there all right
mike gibson says art bell on his show
did an experiment where he had all his
listeners focus on different things and
every time what they were focusing on
happened oh cool
that's the coast of coast park that's
coast to coast yeah i don't know about
that episode that's cool but what
happened like how do you do that i don't
know can you wonder what you're talking
about yeah can y'all start that what
should we have people focus on like
world peace yeah yeah
there you go getting trump elected
which is world peace well we hope it is
certainly not if you like i want to do a
group meditation we tried this in 2007
but the infrastructure wasn't there but
to do a live video stream where we all
got on and we all meditated together
with our video cameras up and it was
just we tried to do on stickum.com but
it was couldn't handle more than 20
people at a time but we had like
hundreds and hundreds maybe even i don't
know how many but we could do that again
the infrastructure is getting the point
where we could have like 10 000 people
in a video chat yes getting there well i
mean
yeah turn off harp yeah or turn on or
turn it yeah interesting all right so
lay cucumber lime says i used to be
homeless i was taught the magic it's
definitely real you see what you look
for the secret is that it's always been
there awesome congrats on that cool
we should uh
get everybody to focus on something i
don't know
youtube apologizing to steven crowder
yeah everybody just imagine your mind
youtube removing the strike from
crowder's channel and apologizing
admitting they were wrong
50 lashes to themselves reversing their
policies on censorship i mean that
imagine the fbi being disbanded
all right all right okay
the thing about crowder that's crazy is
um it was kerry likes that made comments
about the election
she's the gop primary candidate for
governor what she says is of paramount
importance to this election and they
took it down what so i imagine i didn't
see the episode but that steve just
didn't push back
i don't i don't know i don't know it's
just if you make the claims or whatever
i guess if someone makes a claim like
you got to push back on it on tv
otherwise youtube's like ah they're
promoting it and you're like no but it's
but but what she said wasn't even about
the like trump she was talking about
arizona's i don't know exactly what was
said but that's either way it shouldn't
matter
someone who is going to potentially be
the governor like is saying things i'll
tell you this if the fear is those ideas
would hurt republicans then youtube's
helping republicans i guess because now
the moderates aren't going to be hearing
those things democrats will struggle to
use it as a weapon
all right sleep in the sleep is the
cousin of death says good things happen
to me equals magic aka narcissism but
i'll go one step further they weren't
just saying like all these good things
happen to me it must be magic they were
saying like i have chosen for a thing to
happen to me and it did with acting you
notice it in the entertainment industry
a lot it's more sensitive because your
your mood when you go into the audition
is a big part of whether or not you get
the role and if you believe you're gonna
get it and you you have that like
confidence and friendliness to you they
love you and they wanna they want you
there
yep ivan ortiz says tim you didn't hear
it from me but it seems ghost girl is a
fed who opposes returning carts when she
shops she failed the test
so that's uh that's mary morgan co-host
of pop culture crisis so the trick is
whenever you're going to hire someone
what you do is you invite them out to
hang out to meet everybody and then you
say
we're going to run to the grocery store
and pick up some drinks and you know
some soda and some pizzas maybe and then
when you go
you bring you you bring the shopping
cart unload it and then you wait to see
if they put it back and if they don't
you don't hire them it's a great test
that's the i always return the cart yeah
but i ride on i run and i jump on it and
ride it yeah it's fun
we were we were talking about this once
with someone we were looking to hire
like as a joke not seriously doing it
and then with like
as we were walking to the car and like
joking like oh yeah i remember the thing
about the shopping cart and then the
dude actually just returned the shopping
cart we started laughing cause we were
like we didn't we weren't seriously
considering doing that but i will say
though like that actually is a good test
is this person willing to do a little
bit extra without reward because it's
the right thing to do i think about that
picking up garbage too if you're walking
down the street you see like a wrapper
just pick it up i actually talked about
this in another interview like a few
years ago because i'm always thinking
about i always return the cart and then
i got a little bat some backlash from
mothers who say uh when they're in the
in the
in the parking lot and they feel a
little uncomfortable sometimes to to
keep their kids safe and whatever
nefarious things might be in their
periphery they just leave the cart
wherever well you know sometimes i get i
grab a couple other carts and i'll
return three of them dang you know so
you're making up for those go above and
beyond i like that yeah you should pay
you those that cannot do i will do for
them anonymous steve says tim thank you
kindly bioshock vibes that's literally
why i say would you kindly
because uh i'm i'm commanding you to do
it so i guess the people who know
bioshock when i say would you kindly
smash the like button
oh funny i'm trying to force you to do
you're manifesting it hulk smash do you
guys
smash the like button i didn't watch it
the car was a video game oh okay i
thought it was the card
it's like based off of uh it's like the
art and ideas of an iron rand into this
kind of game okay such a masterpiece you
really should should play have you seen
it which game uh bioshock oh i've heard
it yeah i've heard it so it's like a
city built underwater called rapture and
it's like objectivist society basically
the it's it's just amazing but uh
it's a very very old game so spoiler
alert for whatever reason but uh
throughout the game there's a guy
talking to you over like a
communications device and he says would
you kindly whenever the game shifts to
like
um the player loses control he's like
would you kindly pull that lever for me
and things like that where you have to
do it and it's because you're mind
controlled when he says would you kindly
it's a command that forces you to do it
so when i say would you kindly smash the
like button it's
mind control yeah right it's a gag i
mean most people don't know the
reference wouldn't i think anything
wouldn't think twice all right we'll
just grab a couple more of these super
chats if it's working because youtube
keeps crashing on us and i don't know
why
i do the manifestation where i'll be
like you subscribed to the channel you
liked it you liked the video as well
and then you just let it roll check this
out
les courier de bois de bois says tim
previously you were talking about bookit
and how you got ads without searching
for it i never did either and the day
after watching your show i started
getting booked it ads like you did love
y'all from quebec
so you you remember book it from pizza
hut not pizza but like you in school you
get the little bookit wheel and if you
read the book you get like a free donut
and you get a pizza you don't remember
this no there's anything maybe so it
didn't happen no jack talks
jack talks about pizza nationalism
and we were talking about how they had
the bookit program where if you finished
the book report you got a wheel and had
coupons on it and then my parents showed
me dunkin donuts i got a free donut we
go to pizza eat the free personal pizza
and then the next day i was it was
pandora actually i was playing music
when i was skating and an ad popped up
and then big blue letters said book it
and i was like what
book it doesn't exist anymore or at
least as far as i know it doesn't and
this ad was for a travel company that
book it i'm like
whatever is spying on me didn't
understand what book it was and assumed
it was a travel thing it tried yeah
unless
you know
people think our devices are spying on
us
some have said it's just the algorithm
predicting our behavior
or it could be that we live in a
simulation
and your reality is constructed by what
you think and see and
that's right so ladies and gentlemen
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel would you
kindly share the show with your friends
and would you kindly become a member at
timcast.com to support our work and
check out all of our shows
it's been a it's been a fun friday night
you can follow the show at tim cast irl
you can follow me personally at tim cast
will you want to shout anything out
uh
other than my twitter i'm at will
chamberlain on twitter that's where most
of my content is going right now also
follow the article 3 project and the
internet accountability project article
three is doing a bunch of good stuff
mike davis uh the guy who runs article
three is doing great commentary on the
fbi raids and their illegality so right
on stuff awesome
i am shane cashman everywhere instagram
twitter and uh you can follow tales from
the inverted world we got the first two
episodes of ghosts of the civil war up
on youtube and uh first episodes on our
facebook at tales from the inverted
world and the rest is on timcast.com
we're on episode seven right now and
it's a blast i'm really proud of our our
team they're killing it and uh looking
forward to the next volume which i've
already started this is like the we need
to get the mobile apps and i know this
is the big hurdle for us
because we've been talking with some uh
ott developers about we've got hitting
up a bunch of a bunch of people have hit
us up about making the app
this is the best show for when you're
like driving home late at night or
you're on a road trip and you just play
every episode and it's just like yeah
that was like one of the best comments
we've gotten was like
someone drove from like l.a to to vegas
listening to inverted world that's
amazing but this is this is what i was
thinking when i was like we got to do
something like this because i remember
when i went on a road trip that's all i
want to do is play ghost stories yeah
call in shows like you know stuff like
that yeah i was like we need something
like that yeah no it's been exciting
it's a great i'm really proud of this
season and i'm looking forward to doing
the next podcast well i'm ian
oh sorry no hey don't even worry shane
i'm more excited about the details from
the inverted world yeah and working on
it with you yeah no that was fun please
check out that interview uh it's on tim
cast it was a lot of fun ladies and
gentlemen you are liking this video
you're smashing the bell button and you
are subscribed to tim cast irl
you are having a great night and good
things are coming to you
bye
beautiful and if with that positive
affirmation i will sign off as well you
guys can follow me on twitter and
minds.com at sarpatchlitz if you guys
want to hear more of my inane ramblings
i do short little instagram lives every
week every day pretty much at about 5 15
p.m at real sarah patriots on instagram
and
also at sourpatchleads.me
tomorrow you will wake up
you will instantly think good thoughts
and feel happy
you will pull up your phone
and go to chickencitylive.com
and then you will laugh and smile as you
watch the silliness of chickens in your
early morning day and the rest of your
weekend from there will be beautiful fun
and exciting thanks for hanging out
everybody and we'll see you all next
time
you